M
yeah yeah I got like a couple
rules to go into it but there's part of
me that's like a you have a code yeah I
have a certain code in terms of
fights I feel like I'm more worried
about legal action afterwards that I'm
like I never do yeah that's the problem
you got to not think about
that that's a good way to get into
fights yeah that's one of my
philosophies of fighting is you don't
think don't think don't think about the
yeah the lawyer the crushing
debt and the legal trouble losing your
family yeah you separate that so you're
cup of
water an angry cup of
water you've been hydrating Hans yeah
nice think so I like to keep my mouth
wet yeah I think it's good for cuz I
smoke a lot of weed and also cuz it's
your voice that you're using for standup
right so I've been like you know people
are like oh you got to just like uh have
a Loz or like drink honey but I think
like drinking water all the time I'm
thinking of getting a camel bag is a
good way to keep your everywhere where
you go
out yeah they're actually really good
bags and then you can have a half bag
for your other [__] yeah I love cam
bags so bad at drinking
water I like always CH choke and spill
I do my water routine starts in the
morning I go to like Starbucks and I get
a ventti ice green tea and then a venty
Ice Water cuz the ice water at Starbucks
the water is filtered and the ice is
filtered oh and it's
free if you get something yeah which I
do so I'm starting I'm starting the day
with uh 40 40 ounces you do that every
day close to it damn yeah they know man
to Starbucks I asked out one of the
baras they said
no and you're like all right I'll just
get a well I'm still hydrator
yeah I'm 40 ounces in I don't need
you skin looks better every time you go
in it's hydrated that's right is
hydration that important for me it is
now I'm on this crazy keto diet so Arash
wants me to do like a gallon a day which
isn't insane but yeah it's good stuff
it's not like it's going to hurt you
yeah yeah I have to do it my face gets a
oily and stuff oh really yeah if I don't
drink because of your ethnicity I think
so oh yeah I think Indians are very oily
and that helps for the Sun and you know
what oil doesn't
like water water science
science Arabian half
stereotyp
yeah that's right how are Koreans in
terms of
water well we're surrounded by it on
three sides oh yeah so you know
well the way of water um but yeah I mean
I don't I don't think we have any
special thing with
water um you know in Korea when you go
they give you like these small ass cups
and you have to keep refilling it and
sometimes they have those paper cups
that you have at offices they love water
coolers they have water coolers
everywhere yeah no water fountains they
think that's gross
ah they do that in the Middle East too
it's just water coolers everywhere yeah
probably because the pipes are gross
though I mean water fountains are gross
yeah that's how always just separated
by it's a good idea keep keep it
organized all these new Millennials
destroying tradition yeah I go to one
goddamn
water yeah yeah uh so what started this
kick of hydration
um jelly roll jelly roll yeah he was
like drinking water is the best all
these other tricks don't work just keep
your voice wet it took you like a 450
lb that's where I
my clicked yeah no water's the [__] very
good water yeah do you did you ever meet
jelly roll yeah how was how is he a guy
imagine he'd be so nice he like hey
what's up man yeah he always greets
everyone like that that's cool yeah it's
so nice to be able to do that I wish I
could do that I know can you imagine
having to do that all day I don't know
if my brain could by like the 30th guy
but yeah up what do you want yeah you
want an
autograph yeah I want to fight you yeah
some people can just turn on that all
day cam Patterson's the same way yeah I
can see him like like 10 minutes into
the night be like he dabs everybody
everywhere he goes and then four hours
later it's
like wow how do you like stay that
energized and like connecting with
people that's not that must be fear of
social ostracization could be I don't
know it's a good one to have serving him
while I don't think it is though because
this seems negative I guess it's just
he's just so H he's like a dog he sees
other people yeah I've never seen him
upset he's always happy
smiling yeah we should check in on
him those are always
the damn dude we should make sure he
doesn't kill himself yeah try our
best yeah Cam's always up and
Adam are you guys naturally social
people no not really I have to put an
effort to do it m yeah sometimes I don't
even do that not put in any effort it's
hard to especially after the shows when
everyone's rushing you yeah that feels
uh it's stressful sometimes yeah and
it's like what do I bring up in the
convers hey
thanks yeah I've been saying what a
night yeah oh that's a good one yeah
it's not even good or bad it's just it
is a night yeah lately it's been so cold
out
here oh I from here I got this line that
I do now I barked for a show I had this
past weekend
and I gave him a ticket like yeah this
is com show blah blah blah blah and the
end I say and if you can't make it just
support your local Denny and then they
it like disarms them and they're like
and then a couple those people came and
I was like yeah using those Mind Tricks
people that are social are crazy dude I
know I just don't know what to talk
about just don't know yeah how much of
is fake and like how much of it is
genuine interest yeah and at that point
how do you tell the difference
right it's all fake slash
genuine a little bit of being yeah it's
all fake
genuine yeah dude uh I think it's hard
to do without being like socially
unaware like if you're socially unaware
you can be like hey how are you and
people like get out get away and you're
like oh ha that's funny where are you
from you got to be a little [__] I
think that'd be the ideal that's the
best way to make a social person yeah a
little bit but not too much because if
if you go too much then you're like you
get ostracized from being like oh you
don't come to that guy like that you you
have to understand there's like people
in there level those pickup artists are
crazy yeah because you have to like try
to [__] someone after doing something
socially [__] yeah but it works for
them sometimes yeah yeah it's ni I think
like people are like up here like in
their heads like intellectually and then
when they talk they have to like dumb
down so they can communicate and then
hopefully build back up back up wow it
does always start Small Time hey how are
you weather you
know hey what what's a quick way to do
it weather yeah emotion weather mood day
current what are you doing what you
how's your weekend
life okay hey weather life
goal what's up either pick either but
yeah I like real conversations I don't
like conversations that have been done a
hundred times before like yeah yeah
great set man what a night right I want
like to change it up and I don't like
people that just need to like have it be
a normal conversation I want to like
take it off the rails especially if you
can tell the person doesn't [__] with
you you know like why are we doing this
right why are we still going through
this social dance when neither of us
want to be dancing
you know there should be like a a
cordial hey or even a nod or not even a
nod [__] it just like I'm not your enemy
I do not want you to be my enemy but I
do not want to talk to you exactly
there's so many people like that where
it's like I I'm sure as people they're
amazing you know but just not not in my
deck of cards yeah you know especially
where I am especially if I'm about to go
up I'm like that's a big one yeah or
after when you feel you've had a bad set
and then people are like that was so
funny want to punch you right now yeah
you know it's weird with comedy because
everyone thinks that they have a special
Insight because they're being affected
by it emotionally so they're like oh
this is how it affected me here's what
you need to know about what happened to
me during your set right I've been doing
comedy for eight
months no bad comedy the guys are always
like I've been thinking about doing it
you know I'm going to try it soon
they're like cool [__] do it those
guys are really good V that kicks it
yeah because there's like this
undercurrent of I could do that yeah you
know and they could but like put in
eight 10 years right yeah you know they
don't see what you have to and
everyone's journey is so different the
emotional battles everyone has to fight
so like yeah I mean and how people look
like if you look like a pretty girl
you're going to get a different response
so yeah it's easy for you to be likable
but my battle is like the word thing
that you that some people but then
pretty girls they have the the they have
their troubles on the back end yeah they
get famous or they get big fast and then
their standup doesn't meet that level
yet or like they they age out and then
that that starts to like wear on the you
know suddenly everyone's not so
forgiving of their
jokes and then they're like oh [__] you
know these are jokes for eights yeah
yeah yeah exactly these jokes work if
you're a six yeah you got to find jokes
that work yeah I got I got to go to the
depths man I'm working at like a two
sometimes three on a good
day I gota like I got I really got to no
stand up but don't you think you have an
advantage cuz you're so in a good mood
and you look funny
and sometimes yeah yeah sometimes but
other times like if I can't regulate my
emotions to before I'm just like a
bitter fat guy and no one likes a bitter
fat
guy they like a mean fat guy and they
like a happy fat guy but they don't like
a bitter fat guy so that's the battle
that's the battle regulating emotions
yeah like that's the hardest thing of
Comedy I think is like being in that
right State for the show like people
think it's so easy but yeah it's like
anyone can be excited to do it their
first time right be like oh I'm so but
like to do it in and out every day
saying the same thing yeah yeah yeah how
do you do anything before stage if
you're in a shitty mood to get right um
I just try to uh be authentic and just
be like oh this is how I feel or
whatever I don't try to change it I'm
like I could be funny in a bad mood um
but yeah sometimes I like jump around
and try to get the blood
flowing um but yeah I don't uh I try not
to try to change my mood too much I try
to just be like okay this is my mood and
then I work with it but if it's for a
big show I like to be excited I don't
know if it's fake or not but yeah at
least if I'm excited it's good sometimes
and you still get you still get like the
butterflies um yeah I think so it's
weird just all those people staring at
you is naturally weird right yeah then
it's like yeah I want to I don't want to
go up there and be like Oh not this
again I want butterflies I don't want it
to be like trying to tune it out cuz
I've seen that when people tune it out
and it's just like a rehearsal a
recital yeah the audience can tell that
you don't care yeah yeah they can tell
if you not you're not responding to them
if you're not like pushing back and like
do playing tennis with them yeah just on
autopilot yeah because they'll be like
oh haa and then you just go on like you
didn't hear it then they're like oh [__]
what's going on it's like a baby where
you don't pick it up if it's crying and
it's like what it just [__] up its
brain and then it doesn't it doesn't
laugh at your uh you know racist rape
joke this
baby you know yeah it's
nuts yeah it's so weird like
uh sometimes do you listen back to your
recordings yeah I listen back to my
recordings and even on shows where I
think everything is like it's
technically a good set I listen back to
like I hear like the murmurs that you
can't quite hear I'm like other they
saying that I'm [__] that joke suck that
I'm worthless yeah so that's what you
did you made them murmur yeah and then
after all like they're all like ah and
I'm like
no no they love me yeah no no I think
they all despise me and then sometimes
when I have really bad sets I'll be like
they just didn't know what
was have to like lie to yourself some at
least I do I feel like I have to lie to
myself sometimes or like I'll hear that
like a negative comment from you know
some guy or some chick in the back I'll
be like they didn't say that bad thing
they said something good keep
moving that's the best way to take it if
you're looking at it like you're your
own agent you're like keep him happy
yeah it's fine he doesn't need to hear
that that much negativity right and then
slowly put it turn it up when you need
the motivation yeah
yeah you generally
motivated um yeah I think so you know
sometimes I'm like [__] these people I
don't want to make them laugh why is
that just tired or they don't appreciate
me for whatever reason but uh yeah most
of the time it's like that kind of
negativity is easily defeated by the
fact that I'm up there and people are
staring at me and I could be embarrassed
sure so going up really helps cuz then
you're in the moment you're not like in
your own head yeah are you uh do do you
like comedy yeah yeah I don't know your
background what's what I've been doing
it for for eight years on and off but
kind of more seriously the past two
years cuz I was in the military I just
got out like three months ago three four
months ago nice congratulations thanks
yeah but uh yeah I've been because I was
in the military I moved around a lot so
I started in San
Francisco uh went to Hawaii the Middle
East for a year Maryland New York
Florida and here wow all over all over
so I've been in kind of a bunch of
different comedy scenes never long
enough to kind of like start progressing
in my career but hopefully now in Austin
I can kind of I'm staying here for a
while so do you have like a contract
while you're here no I mean I'm I'm out
I just got a normal job and yeah just
grinding to nice what do you think of
the scene so far it's great man I came
out here Cu uh I was friends with uh Cam
and jolly and all those Orlando guys and
so coming out here I already had like
guys to plug in with and it's been fun
such a cool scene yeah R dude yeah yeah
hell yeah uh what was Orlando the
Orlando seem like it was cool it was
small so it's like there's only a
handful of like really good comics and
there was a they have the Improv which
is hard to break into so they're like
everybody kind of relied on like the
local showcases there's a great room
called milk district and uh that was
like The Home Room and it was fun good
mics like unlike Austin like the mics
here you rarely get a unless it's like
the creek mik or or Cap City or
something but uh compared to what scene
Florida Florida yeah you get like 20 30
people at like a that's people go to our
shows exactly yeah you have good shows
here so there's no point going it's must
to be tough for up and comers yeah
that's what I've noticed about Austin is
like the open mic scene is so separate
from the rest of the comedy suit yeah
yeah there's a big golf unfortunately
unless you go to San Marcus
apparently that's why I really liked um
they had it for a second when they had
Romo room but I really like the slotted
at least when I was beginning and I
probably would like it now cuz you could
have mics during the day but the slotted
system where you get like eight comics
in an hour doing five minutes you sign
up before you can't be late but then
it's only 50 minute to an hour time
commitment and you can do it all day and
then in that time
you're getting guaranteed
spots and you're meeting all those seven
other Comics mhm but Austin doesn't seem
to have a system like that here and it
shouldn't be you shouldn't have to pay
for that that's what happened in La
whereas $5 for five minutes yeah and it
was just kind of like a money-making
machine but if you could do a free
version of that all we need is someone
that can find a place that would let
someone do it there for free like a
slotted mic yeah do you think we could
revolutionize the mic game maybe and
that way you don't have to wait for
signing up because that would save so so
much time yeah they could use that and
they could do community service yeah
yeah and you can get I like the aspect
of having things during the day because
there's the people that have jobs but
there's some people who don't and they
can go to a 4 pm mic five and if you're
doing it in chunks of hours you can do
them all night right and then the people
who have work early can go to the late
ones and vice
versa would there be an audience though
no that's the thing is like the eight
Comics who sign up for the hour they
have to stay till the end it's like a
writing Workshop yeah pretty much but I
found it really helpful when I was uh in
La doing it cuz I could cuz I worked as
a door guy at night at the comedy store
so I could hit Mike starting at like 300
p.m. and then do three sometimes four of
those before my shift and that's 20
minutes for open mik is pretty good was
that at the thing next to the building
where during the pandemic they have like
a tent up yes yeah yeah and now they
have a bunch all over the city and like
two or three companies that do it
because that's so cheap to set up M we
could do that yeah it's manageable for
sure yeah I just I don't want to do any
work I'm fine I'm doing I'm doing shows
and this [__] but it would be nice to
isn't that so much worse to do that
because then it's like you're not
getting a real reaction it's hard to
tell what they think is actually funny
they're jaded and whatever that's what I
thought but I think it trains you to
kind of just speak your mind about
things CU once you do like 20 of those
you're like oh [__] this [__] I'm just
going to talk uhhuh and then you talk
and then you actually find really funny
premises who of things you actually
believe yeah you know it's a good
writing exercise yeah for sure it's not
like the real thing no no it's it's it's
the thing before the real thing yeah so
then you take those ideas and then you
go to an actual mic with a actual crowd
or a show yeah you know yeah I like the
creek mic the Sunday one that one got a
good audio is audience yeah eight eight
ni and then banana phones later mhm cool
yeah yeah Creek has some good
mics yeah it's a good vibe it makes
sense that there's a good mic there
everyone's like oh this is cheap and
easy to access and everyone can go there
so everyone ends up there yeah it's not
like uh you know like one of these paid
clubs where it's like harder to get in
unless you know somebody or you work
there yeah Creek you can go there and
not buy anything right yeah Creek is a
good hang for all levels yeah and
there's so much space too between inside
and outside yeah or if you just want to
sit and watch yeah it's a good hang MH
cheap drinks it's good for all the
alcohol yeah and food food truck right
there has everything yeah it's good for
comedians to just go and get charge
their phones and get out there right go
sleep in their
cars is that how does it uh I mean it's
been a while since you've been in a van
but
like uh that's what I did when I was in
New York just recently no when I was
when you started for the pandemic yeah
yeah I was I was walking up with a huge
sling of water and Rebeca saw me she was
like I was thinking that she was going
to be mad but she was like oh watch
where you
going yeah stealing water from her place
that's so
funny yeah that big Jeffrey and I always
used to take a bunch of water bottles
from The Comedy Store the thirsts is
what their the brand
is so I would always have like five six
thirsts in my car at any time and it was
nice because if anyone drove with me be
like hey do you want a water I felt like
a fancy Uber
yeah staying
hydrated that's the name of the game do
you miss the van life yeah I miss seems
fun not having no one know where I live
yeah now I have to put it down on the
form everyone knows like the [__]
mechanic needs my address yeah but yeah
I would just put in a random address and
then nobody knows where I am and I can
just fall asleep anywhere my house is
always right outside I don't have to
Uber
anywhere um but yeah it's better to be
inside overall right it's just cool to
be like Oh I'm doing it I don't need
anything it's good to not have anything
you're not carrying anything with you
yeah like when I was traveling to Miami
and the pandemic hit I could just leave
it's like there's nothing tying me to
anywhere especially in the beginnings of
Comedy there is something to be said
about uh the value of having nothing is
is is a pretty freeing thing it sucks
ass sometimes but past that yeah it's
it's uh you're like someone could shoot
me in the [__] head right now and no
one would care and so what would I
say what will I say at this 3 pm open
mic with five
minutes people who hate me yeah in a
field I'm not respected and I could do
whatever I want you know what I mean
like pretty freeing thought yeah you
have nothing to lose
yeah I could I could
I could go next door to the 7-Eleven and
shoot
somebody who cares you know yeah like
you can walk in anywhere and it's a net
benefit for you mhm right everything is
free it's just all you have nothing and
you're getting something so it's all
valuable and that's what I'll say to the
poor when I run as Republican
president everything's a benefit
everything's benefit it's just how you
look at well that's how I feel about
Denny's man like things don't have to be
good to be great you know you're just
doing a promo
now yeah man it really is it's like part
of the appeal of Denny's is that it's
not good yeah you can relax you don't
have to be like excuse me sir this is a
cold hash brown yeah of course it is
[__] your you know but you're with
friends yeah it's like oh I don't have
to be on edge because it is going to
suck so so that's that's going to happen
and then I can move on from there yeah
man instead of constantly be worrying
like oh it's going to suck I hope it
doesn't suck it's like okay it is g to
suck is it worth the money you know
you're thinking about money one day
we're
gonna have money and then we're going to
be like this steak isn't appropriate
temperature and they're going to be like
oh of course you know and they're going
to because bow to the whims but not at
Denny's at Denny's they hand you life
you know this is the current economic
status yeah yeah exactly this is what
you
deserve and it's okay you know and they
can all street fight and [__] like that
yeah you know like Waffle House Waffle
House is a little too dangerous for my
taste but to each his own yeah has there
ever been a grease fire in Waffle House
spread to the customers really fast
probably lives well spent
that's the price of cheap waffles yeah
you wanted a waffle for $2 you're on
fire figure it
out you guys go to Denny's I like
Denny's yeah I grew up on Denny's nice
yeah there's a big California thing
because I don't really I didn't really
go to IHOP are you like IHOP no no I
don't I don't mind IHOP but I think
Denny's is a just class is a standard
for me it seems more like a real
restaurant Den like a real din yeah IHOP
seems like a European like it seems like
Ikea for breakfast yeah maybe it's cuz
it's blue yeah it's something about the
blue that's off-putting it's not
American no it's not it's International
yeah you got that red and Denny's red
and the red of crimson and the yellow of
[Laughter]
sun yeah so you you had a lot of Denny's
in California yeah all the time live
right buy one it's the best what was the
uh what was that Denny like it's shitty
you walk in the lights are dim and the
floor is dirty as hell nice and they
that they had that corner where they
have like games and stuff did you have
that at your Denny's yeah yeah the claw
yeah they have the claw machine and
maybe like another one other game and
everything all the tables are kind of
like greasy yeah yeah yeah the one that
was in my neighborhood it was owned by
an Indian family so it felt like I was
going to an Indian restaurant every time
nice how was the food [__] I mean it was
just shitty
normal diner food totally yeah that's
great yeah just a basic Denny's open 24
hours yeah that's the thing Austin
doesn't have any more 24-hour places
Denny's is one of the few refuges yeah
no place of of Refuge refuges refuges
ref I would like a famous diner here in
Austin I forgot what it's was called
somebody said it was like a classic
Diner in
Austin do you know what it might be no
it's like right off the you'll have to
be more specific 35 I I have to look it
up we went in there it was shitty I
asked ordered a burger and they're like
we don't have any burger meat and I was
like all right I'll take the chicken
tenders they're like oh Kirby Lane maybe
it wasn't Kirby Lane cuz I think I went
to Kirby Lane after and it was good but
this place was [__] garbage and at
least like super fancy it looked like at
one point it was probably a cool ass
Diner I have to look it up it's probably
bought by Walmart May Stars I think it
might be Stars was it by a motel it felt
like it was by a motel I don't remember
if it was that's probably star yeah it
was shitty as hell yeah I didn't have it
felt like a front I ordered everything I
could and they're like we don't have
anymore yeah and I went in the morning
when you're supposed to have
everything you don't have eggs the [__]
yeah I ordered everything I ordered she
was like let me go check she came back
and she like we don't got it
sucks God I love I love some breakfast I
found a Denny's in Canada when we
went Vancouver yeah there was a
Denny's I yeah I mean there's Denny's
everywhere fun little fact and you know
we can talk about something else soon
but Denny's used to be Danny's Donuts
wasn't Denny's at all and then they
changed one letter who cares what it's
supposed to be yeah yeah no more Donuts
just Denny's got most of the consonant
in it yeah yeah started in California
actually so that explains why the
California has the second most amount of
Denny's Texas has the most in Florida
third I
believe yeah so you know if you're
planning a trip or something good enough
keep that in mind those are the states
that don't mind poisoning their
population yeah no you know it is what
it is come at your own risk this is
America it's like good enough to be a
food that you eat out with but cheap
enough so that you can do it over and
over again yeah exactly where else you
going to get a coffee and and chicken
fingers at 400
a.m. yeah for a while there was two
Denny's on the same street like right
across from each other really it was
weird they were like competing Denny's
yeah they're just both you could see
both signs from either one is it just
like a extra room for one it's over over
uh packed I wonder if they work together
if they were combative like a Israel pal
sign situation I don't know but I only
went to one of them I didn't go to the
other one I had a favorite you found you
found a home yeah that's where where you
rep the weirdest Denny's we have in
Austin is there's a Denny's up north and
it's connected to a Burger King I
believe it's connected like you can walk
to the Burger King yeah you can walk
between Burger King it's not really like
a thing that you want both of you don't
want pancakes and a burger it's either
one or the other and you can get burgers
at
Denis so it's like man man what a place
that's wild yeah that's both filling
filling food yeah and one's sit down and
one's fast food
yeah so you can get [__] now and you
can get shitty food for later yeah I
think that that location is probably
like a litness test to like some
billionaire
who you know who needs to figure out you
know what type of person goes where yeah
cuz like is it more shameful to be in
the Denny's and see the Burger King or
from the other perspective is it more
shameful to be in the Burger King and
see the people at Denny's which is which
yeah it's like at least we're not trying
you're acting like you're at a real
restaurant sitting down right yeah the
enemy next
door yeah dude yeah I mean it's
like a guy on coke was like everyone
loves Burger King everyone loves Denny's
why don't we combine it
but why don't we combine you know like
Chick-fil-A and you know Panda Express
remember those like fast food
restaurants that like KFC Pizza Taco
Bell Taco Bell yeah yeah you don't have
to can e pizza and a taco yeah I mean
those places worth the [__]
honestly I almost felt like I had to
order one from each restaurant I know
you can't cuz and then it's like what
then what's the point of all of this
yeah if I don't dabble if I don't enjoy
both then what why is this monstrosity
here yeah what a place you guys ever eat
at like the McDonald's Walmart combos of
course of course yeah those are
convenient yeah those are convenient
Walmart gets it they get America Walmart
is what America should look like outside
just with like the narrow aisles and
walkability it's like the only place you
can actually feel like you're in Europe
is in a gross
yeah totally I although I'm mad at the
Walmarts right now because the Walmarts
and Austin at least they're they're not
24 hours anymore and I think that's with
most Walmarts and the whole appeal was
like I want to go in and get a 2 L of
purple Fizz for you know 60 cents at 4
in the morning yeah and then it's like
well it feels like they're willing
taking second third place which is so
unamerican to Amazon it's like you know
Amazon's going to beat you but it's like
put up a
fight you're weak right now yeah us your
Walmart's as like a Ford operating base
start pouching Amazon truck exactly put
a McDonald's and put a KFC Pizza Hut
Taco Bell step upap to the market a
Denny's Walmart would be sick that'd be
nice oh that would be so cool dude I
would love to like just park your cart
next to your table Yeah sweet Park the
cart next to table eat some Denny's then
go shop vice versa yeah you could be in
a Denny's eating pancakes and have a
flat screen
TV that'd be so dope yeah you don't have
to go anywhere else no spend your whole
day there we got to find the people to
talk to these are conversations that you
know CEO should be listening to
yeah but they don't want listen to the
little guy no they have their fancy
ideas they think they know best they
they put all their questions in a
robot these are real ideas with real
people right Indian Korean fat all
together diverse I think this is mostly
your
idea hey we all share we all share the
wealth we all share the blame all the
best if I had money I'd invest
yeah Den yeah I mean just can you
imagine the
fights you know a Walmart fight breaks
into the Denny's fight yeah yeah Witch
is
witch it's like when they did that
campaign for like the witch side of the
Twix or you
on did you start a fight in Denny's or
did you start a fight in
Walmart up to
you you choose your adventure does does
Walmart here sell guns cuz I know so
Walmart's don't anymore it's hard to
find a Walmart in town oh is it but I
think it's more respectable to start a
fight in Denny's because Walmart it's
like this is where people need to go get
food so this is more desperate but
Denny's it's like optional it's like oh
I'm eating out someone else is cooking
the food yeah and then I get mad at
someone it's like oh I don't need this
but if you're getting into fights at
Walmart there goes your grocery store
yeah it's like survival yeah yeah people
are more desperate there is higher
consequences yeah if we do this Denny's
Walmart thing you know people could lose
a
lot destroying fames yeah can't eat
anywhere it could destroy the nuclear
family but it might be a risk we'd have
to take you know yeah at least one just
see how it goes yeah just put it in a in
one of those cities where you know like
they they do all the experiments on yeah
you know some some town in Ohio or
something in the middle of a cornfield
there's like a population of like four
or 5,000 and you just open one of those
and you don't say anything and you just
Watch What Happens have tons of cameras
everywhere and microphones Mr yeah it's
a Mr Beast video yeah yeah we get Mr
Beast to front the the cost of the
initial investment we'll probably just
need 2030 million to make a Walmart
Denny's and then it's still making money
on the back end you know you got to buy
all that [__] to sell it it's a lot
that's scary what if you have all that
[__] and no one buys
it yeah well then you start uh taking
that plastic and then you start
converting it to cheese and then you
sell that at the Denny's and then it's
an ecosystem yeah it's all recyclable
into Denny's
food you can buy this bike made out of
pancakes yeah yeah exactly bike made out
of Pancakes
look at this chair made out of
bacon you know you can just buy Denny's
furniture for your house yeah buy a
booth the Denny's merch is actually
pretty dope they got some good they got
some good merch I've been looking at the
visor they got visor they got bags I got
anything you could want really it's
weird they have merch 7-Eleven has a
merch now too which is weird that's dope
I buy uh the Kirkland Costco merch I
like Kirkland that's funny it's a solid
brand I used to get Kirkland because my
dad and my uncle were big Costco guys
and so we would they would always buy
Kirkland shirts and I would be like so
pissed because I wanted like a real
shirt and and now Kirkland is a brand I
couldn't see it in my youth and my
ignorance but now they're they're coming
back and I I bought Costco hoodies
Jeffrey and I bought matching Costco
hoodies I got like Kirkland sweater that
I
love I got one that just says Costco
Wholesale and sometimes I'll wear it in
the Costco and people think I work there
it's dope yeah Costco is a funny brand
because it's like it's not very cool
it's not serious it's like practical
value yeah there's the cheapest thing
that we can Mass produce in our current
economy no but like Kirkland is like the
highest level of the cheap [__] it's
good quality is it's good quality they
to take TR toilet paper but not too much
yeah exactly you got to have grit yeah
you still got to you still still want to
feel your clothes yeah you still want a
little sand in your
boots but you know it uh like the toilet
paper at Kirkland is amazing it's like
very high quality toilet paper you can
get six cartons of oat milk for like
nine
bucks it oh and then of of course what
am I saying
the classic is one of the Classics for
me at least is $5 rotisserie chicken and
it's huge that's cheaper than you'd get
in the grocery store and it's so much
chicken yeah yeah and they cook it so
good M yeah I think they use a pressure
cooker cuz the water gets all the way in
and everything is soft it all stay and
that's the I mean people take it for
granted but you buy one of those
rotisserie chicken and that's the
product of experimenting on billions of
chickens to get to that chicken
probably you know yeah do you think
they've outpaced the experiments with
actual perfect chickens at this point
yes they're going to a new
place yeah now there are more chickens
that are don't haven't been experimented
on we just figured it out yeah sorry
chickens you're kind of
dumb we know how to make you delicious
and that's your fault yeah we're
systemically gonna [__] eat you
yeah oh and then of course uh Costco you
go to get the Hot Dog Soda a buck 50
it's a great deal MH yeah yeah it's like
our
Ikea because Ikea is the same kind of
thing meatballs yeah meatballs and cheap
and it's it's cheap food that you can
eat if you're a
homo no I don't it's very good food uh I
like their meatballs and the LinkedIn
Berry sauce oh yeah yeah yeah it's good
so why haven't you been going up you
could have gone Sunday and Monday for
the open mic right I could have I've
been in a a slump dude a major
depression I'm trying to work myself out
of that do you want some
drugs no it's going to make me worse
thank you though okay that's funny that
you have
depression what do you think that is I
don't know if it's the weather or just
like my General State I'm also on this
like crazy keto diet right now that
might be affecting my mood changing your
body chemistry mhm so you just have to
muscle you just start it uh I've been on
it for like two and a half weeks and
then I've been working out for about
three months now
roughly so it's slow moving but once I
started the ketosis I was just I'm just
rapidly losing weight hell yeah dude
yeah which needed yeah I'm down 25 so
far and then you know going to try to
keep that moving and then I'm on the
diet for another
I think four to five weeks and then I
slowly start to introduce other foods
like beans and other types of I'm sure
maybe a carbohydrate or two but right
now I'm on like very very little to no
carbs and little to no sugar which is
going against everything that I know you
know this might be
Ari
hello Ari the Estonian okay let me open
the
door so that's cool you're on a diet I'm
on a diet this is unsweetened tea nice
you're doing the coolest body
transformation possible Right our
society is obsessed with yeah exactly
hello it's going to translate to a lot
of viewership do you have a go you're
trying to get down to I want to be a fat
guy that can uh
do things that you would wouldn't think
a fat guy would be able to like
somersaults cart
wheels yeah there's this guy called the
the fat free runner on Instagram and
he's this like fat guy but he's built
and he can like do all these crazy
parkour moves and flips yeah so I
thought on stage like how nuts would it
be if you just saw this fat guy like do
a
flip
yeah and then there's also my friend and
I bought racing suits from a thrift
store so I really want to fit into a
racing suit like a race car driver kind
of suit yeah like a yeah that's like a
jumpsuit yeah like a jumpsuit and then I
got Oakleys yeah and I'm going to rent a
convertible and just drive through the
town and stare people down let's see
what's
up come on in tight
squeeze s late no worries thanks for
coming you went swimming
yes it was beautiful yeah yeah the water
is warmer than outside so you can swim
for you were swimming
outside the bar Springs that's Estonian
as
[__] they he it or something it don't do
nothing for me really so if you take
your bike a bit farther there's another
like a natural water there yeah that
[__] me up dick goes straight in and it
stays in a wild you know have you ever
had that no so cold that your dick goes
inside your body yeah you mean
everything goes it's just gone like a
Barbie yeah yeah like a yeah and then
you're going to get it
out so uh yeah I mean uh what do you do
in the water you do laps or get water
just try to be cold try to look at your
dick underwater
yeah boom just throw this right
here boom welcome to the show this is
Ari Maddie mson sure every time you get
worse uh just sorry Maddie is that
really hard is it tell me I mean I
thought every time they said your name
people were calling you Ari Manis the
other day which is another com well yeah
yeah I had that incident that the
mothership where I was running on stage
when they Manis we almost took an old
lady out so embarrassing yeah Adam
everybody was in the back as a little
boy yeah so
embarrassing this did AR get mad at you
was he like this [__] tring come
at my spot no no as soon as I realized
that he's on stage I literally took a
like I dived I dove you Dove I dove you
did like a baseball yeah it was very
embarrassing but Ari mat is not that
hard Hans skim Ari M but then on your
Instagram you have a third name AR m
musan
m yeah but that's just my full name
should I change it yeah why are you
going by your middle name yeah no it's
there's no middle name my first name is
arat but oh really I thought about doing
like a show Bas thing do you do you guys
do show what's your oh do yeah I mean
you all [__] up what's your real name
that's my real name what do you mean
ethnically I'm [__] up no like with a
full what's H Kim I don't have a middle
name Hans kimton my career name is Kim
Kim hang see exactly so you oh that's
fine you should have done that see what
I thought was I should westernize also
but then I got high and read Arnold
Schwarzenegger's book and he said you
know if I can make it with my my name
you know yeah keep it real he does have
a weird name and it has backfired badly
people can't find me they don't know who
I am it has backfire R mat is good
because it's one 12 one2 yeah but the
Maddie then they put a why and then I
paid for Instagram uh check mark check
mark to come up quicker right I thought
that would work but then I post a
picture of my ass and now I'm like
Shadow band or something I pict on my
naked ass it's just funny I have a great
ass is that a problem apparently
apparently we Instagram isn't an
American country anymore you watch
people die though every all day long on
Instagram yeah yeah my feet don't get
that I know yeah people have shown me
their feeds my feets uh my feet is only
chicks 20 chicks chicks and you're
Explorer only yeah I don't do open
Explorer Jes I'm not a [__]
psychopath I have [__] to do who goes to
explore you I don't go on it I don't go
on it you just know what your brain is
thinking based on your explore page
accounts come up anyway tits come up
like other tits come up every day yeah
well that's a famous or a funny bit by
dumbfounded where he's like yeah it's
like [__] I'm not this horny
Instagram is pushing me to be this horny
I think there's like a concerted effort
to make people a little bit more horny
than they should be for sure oh for sure
what's the benefit of making everyone
horny I don't know you s I think it's
just you get horny you want to buy a car
I think it's just like horniness is
something we can do and that's just what
companies see when they see people they
just make them horny that's their
biggest thing that they can do to people
I don't think they're even thinking
about it that much it doesn't seem
malicious no probably no it's definitely
malicious yeah they just want you to
[__] be an AP all day it's malicious
but that's all s on evil if you're a guy
who jacks off during the day that's a
cycle of consumerism you know you start
if you I used to have a bit that like
jacking off is like a it's like pizza
you know it's not a daytime activity
like if you start your day off it's
going to D like there's no smart
decisions with a morning piz that's the
thing though it's uh when I haven't
jerked off and I'm all horny it's like
if I don't jerk off then I'm not
productive the rest of day sometimes I
got to clear that [__] out of my mind
because and then it's like you know but
I can't make it a habit it's just like
when it hits you know when when you're
at the peak of like and yeah yeah fair
you got you got to just jump past the
the threshold and get back to yourself
but then but see but you need to know
where the no don't get me wrong I check
off every day all day every day uh every
day all day I watch porn on
Twitter all day thank you Elon there is
but if but you should that threshold
being aware of that threshold that's the
key right when do you really need to get
it out or or when it is the thing of
like like when you're on the road I just
do Ito I just do it to be like end of
chapter 17 onto chapter 18 it just
refreshes the memory clears out the cash
but I'm so lazy and it's just in that
washing
that actually touch
yourself well um but uh yeah I don't
know I don't there's a there's a limit
somewhere and every couple of months I
find my limit yeah yeah yeah whether
it's sweet [__] nighttime eating yeah
yeah drinking oh drinking in America
with your meat dude I wake up and I'm
done I wake up and I feel like tired
feel something wrong just got to adapt
to it I'm
slowly trust me I'm slowly yeah yeah
what was the diet back in Estonia no or
you were in Canada meets I was in
Estonia I used to live in Canada I mean
they're the same as you guys are like
it's just like you have they have Denny
too but there's uh what's the team
Hortons that they have yeah yeah but uh
oh yeah and I fall straight into it like
it's just like in like a smaller colder
country there's no such thing as a 2
a.m. meal you know all that is is Jagger
meister and [__] that's what you can
get at 2 a.m. right but here it's like I
mean from gigs when I'm highest [__]
high and you're searching for that
stimulation it's got to keep going and
I'm walking back to my Airbnb everything
things flashing well we were just
talking about how it's not open 247
anymore so we're like there used to be
even more so no fair that is true that
before that's funny that in like colder
countries things aren open because you
don't want your delivery driver to
freeze to death like it's not worth it
to have a burger no we have delivery too
but as a former communist you know just
uh do you guys okay this is a good
question do you guys deliver groceries
no I go get it I do you do yeah it saves
so much
time done both but it does take it take
a ton of time it saves time and you know
why it saves money because you're not I
mean the algorithm makes its own sales
pitches but there's nothing stronger of
a sale pitch than walking through a
store you know just that so whenever I
go shopping I just
buy how many times just go to the store
and I literally don't get anything I
wanted I get a 100 you know when you pay
$100 and you leave the store and you're
like I don't have dinner you just bought
[__] weird so that was on sale I don't
yeah right but I still do yeah but I
can't yeah I've ordered groceries a
couple of times but it feels like you're
a king and you're ordering someone to do
something that you should really be
doing yourself like you're spoiled a
little bit when you're order groceries
it's like your one thing you have to do
for your survival yeah show your face
get people to know you greet the pretty
clerk at the counter so that people know
you exist it's a great way to establish
an
alibi grer but yeah I mean gross
ordering groceries is such a decadent
thing and it's only like 10 bucks but it
saves at least two hours yeah but then
you go to the store [__] you move a
little bit and you see some [__]
[__] at the register you get angry
about it I feel like people are a little
pissy right now I feel like before
people were like nicer and it was more
pleasant but ever since the pandemic we
were like what do you want yeah customer
service is gone you were just jerks
people left that industry then it didn't
serve them at all right yeah they
like yeah well now and now they replaced
it with tip screens which is a hell of
its
own the emotional trauma tips are a full
panic attack city for me it's such a
traumatic experience every I don't know
and
I don't want to tip more than I have to
you know what I'm saying right right but
you but you don't want to be the guy
that doesn't tip either I know yeah I
know I know but but why why for all
these cases why well something that I
noticed about Americans is that they're
very nervous about what service industry
thinks about them like in Korea you yell
at your waiters treat them like [__]
yeah you treat them like [__] which I
don't think is do
they do they get a higher wage though
your friends will sell you out so that
you're
too in Korea the waiter I've been there
they wait lay at you too like and that's
don't put it there yeah Forks are right
there in in Melbourne there's a huge
Korean Community used to go to a Korean
restaurant to ride cuz it was the
cheapest one buffet nine bucks right and
he fills the plate up but he would tell
me where to sit just cuz I [__] his day
up you know I'm sit there and right like
an hour and just keep refilling my water
and he'd be like you right there and he
would like take a chair and I get it you
you make us look busy yeah yeah yeah and
always like what do you what do you know
oh they would give you a sheet you do
the whole thing you write down what you
want right yeah yeah and no English
either that's what I like [__] English I
don't want that restaurant if I feel
welcome I don't want to the best best
Chinese spots it's where it's like
forest forest [__] house you sure the
whole menu and picture you're not
talking a lot they're not talking to you
a lot nothing and they're angry that
you're there like oh now we got this
[__] piece of [__] that's great
that's a great place to always the best
yeah yeah you know when they make it or
like a you know do you have like Kebab
places here yeah then there's like all
these Kebab places as well where you go
in and they're like [__] this and you're
like an inconvenience for their day and
they shave it the C there's no way you
should be happy doing that if it's
actually good and you actually put care
into it you should be ashamed that
you're giving it to me so easily right
now yeah I'm getting this too
conveniently this is too much of a good
thing I need a little negativity to be
like oh yeah this is a normal experience
now right uh I remember because I used
to actually go to service school and
there used to be uh my one of my
teachers said it was a a six month
course uh that I got through High School
uh didn't want to do math um but uh he
told me that is there a what is that
customer King is that like in English as
well customer is always right oh
customer we we have like customers King
and he said that now it's not that much
so it's now
because it's yeah because it's so
specific now and there's so many options
everybody has a business now right I
mean what was that South Park about Yelp
you know yeah everyone thinks that
they're the person but if there's so
many then no one is yeah yeah yeah and
then if you yeah now the quality I'm
okay the quality is on camera currently
trying to get a work visa they want to
do a federal crime um oh in America yeah
so okay well you're a good person it's
only me I'm a bad person and we're not
even discussing what this is a cigarette
yeah it's a green cigarette green
cigarette very
popular I uh yeah I mean Europe they act
like they're so much better than us but
we got legal weed and gay marriage here
first and service wise Europe is not
even American there's nothing like
American Service I remember I went to
Atlanta
Georgia like five six years ago first
time I was for two weeks never have I
would sometimes get one time at a diner
they just like when Americans hear my
accent they always [__] me up yeah I
even got like like free sunglasses the
other day at a you know those secondhand
store like $50 I was trying them on he
was like oh they look so good and you
have them but just because I have that
weird people like to be hospitable here
and you guys are proud that you're the
sh
M at our job like I remember I went to
this Diner in Atlanta and this lady was
like where you know with that cute ta
and where you from you know I'm Lon
they're all like shut up you know and
they brought out they're like Fred all
out Fred come see this guy says he's
from Estonia and they Google get the
[__] all threee there don't talk to each
other packs of Pancakes the chef riffing
with me now do you think if we went over
to Estonia that'
be used to be a server Americans you
guys tip that's true but you're allow
and you order stuff that you want yeah
you know in of for the kitchen yeah yeah
okay that's interesting well yeah I
heard Europeans don't talk to strangers
like Americans do Americans will be like
wow what a crazy day like oh nice hat
but you're Spanish Doo and [__] like
that but Eastern Europe is a very like
yeah that's very like and I used to hate
it growing up cuz I always watch
American movies and get influenced by
American Media and I think I want to be
like Dave Chappelle you know go into a
barber shop and ref you know but now
that I'm here dude it's so taxing
Estonia is so cool you at the gig is the
first sentence I'll talk all day there's
no you know yeah and it's actually a
relaxing thing we were just talking
about social niceties before you got
here like there's uh I think it's here
in the US that there's especially an
emphasis on like oh everyone has to have
a conversation even if they don't like
each other or you know or those people
that you don't necessarily dislike but
you don't want to have a conversation
with you still have to do the social
dance of how are you how's everything
going in reality we could just skip all
that and and just [__] go about our
days and be cordial you know yeah I
think it's the main character syndrome
cuz we're used to Hollywood movies and
every scene you have to make a thing or
else it's not wor or maybe I should
reach out to my enemies cuz that's what
a hero would do but you shouldn't you
know yeah you should just let them R
right do your own that's right that's
right how many comedians think that I
deeply have a hatred for them and I'm
just
not what we talking about yeah dude
there's so many yeah yeah I've heard
yeah I heard so many things I just want
to be like I'm not your enemy but I
don't want to talk to you and I love you
that's an insane thing to say here you
know right yeah to say I don't want to
talk to you that's an insane thing to
say honestly that is an insane thing to
say just Express the sentiment I was
just TR to yeah true but you have to
play the game Hans are you telling
yourself or
me oh my god oh yeah yeah with that yeah
that cordialness but but then again you
go to like New York and it's just that
that even though Americans at heart
you're super hospitable and nice when
you just when there's competitiveness in
the air that all goes out the window in
New York literally like they you like
well in China it's the same when went to
China and [__] just run into you and
that's not even an interaction
worthy that in Eastern Europe with our
space we have so much space you know
that's that's a assault you know that's
okay you know right is that how you
fight but you can yeah you like to tuck
it in tuck it in mhm okay I just as
crazy and silly as possible yeah is
silly is intimidating in fights very
intimidating yeah especially if you move
so fast cuz if you're like at a faster
level than the other person they're like
whoa and everybody's High here you know
yeah smoking your Devil's lettuce which
I've never tried why haven't you tried
it it's disgusting and I don't want to
commit a federal crime so if you were
back in the segregation America you
would
have follow the rules you would have uh
been angry at people that were
protesting against
ation weird way to go about whatever
whatever whatever 50 1% once I mean okay
that's where the tickets are at yeah
whatever
pleases like I did I used to be a pretty
not clean but I've never said offensive
words at comedy Mothership it's already
I'm fitting in yeah yeah yeah yeah sure
yeah so is a different clientele then
you go do that same set at Cap City and
then they're
like
liberalism yeah it's
crazy yeah I think uh that uh yeah like
when you're uh what you were talking
about earlier like when people bump into
you and like how there's competition but
there's also cordiality and Americans
feel the need to always be like saying
hi to each other I think it's just a lot
mentally some times and it's like just
because you have a thought on someone
doesn't mean it's like good that you
share it like oh I hate this guy that
you don't have to like be like I hate
you you can just like be like hey what's
up but everyone feels like they have to
express themselves all the time which is
great because you know where everyone
stands but I think you need both I think
it's good to have both because you don't
want too much of you know
Estonia but you also don't want too much
like fakery MH but yeah that is true and
uh is there is there a thing in America
as well at least in Estonia there's a
thing that young people just like now
it's like 15year olds have like anxiety
you know and it's like what cuz they're
so aware of everything now you know
what's going on and they're so connected
to it you know they're watching like
Ukraine on Tik Tok and [__] yeah they
get to worry about war and see it every
day yeah it's just weird and and now
they are like like social anxiety you
know mhm like yeah you if like uh even I
say people like in their younger 20s the
conversational Gap just people's General
ability to hold conversations and ask
people questions is so low here specific
the US yeah they're like into the weird
hobbies and they have like 17 of the
very specific ones that if you don't
like they don't understand you yeah you
don't like
marbles you know yeah but there there is
something to be said that's kind of
[__] scary because those people are
going to grow up and not know how to
communicate with people but when you do
connect it's really deep like job
interviews I remember on Twitter I would
read like all these kids just tweeting
in Estonian and they all like just tweet
about like oh I can't get a car license
CU I can't you know face the [__]
instructor wild but to be fair I mean
school was pretty intense you know sure
I didn't [__] going to like a new
class did you guys switch you were a bad
student right terrible really but but uh
teachers would still like me but that I
would always change I would have to
change schools often and [__] but then
again then again it's just it's one of
those weird dilemas you know it's weird
to weird to say that trauma is good it's
just a weird I'm not I don't agree with
that if if you would have let me pick as
a kid I would have never had those
experience that I did right but then
after when you're grown up yeah job
interview
like and people think bullying stops
after school dude you ever get your
first boss and you're like oh this
[__] was bullied in high school had
no power position just cuz he's a nerd
[__] dick who has no dreams and
committed to this [__] job he's now
above me he's going to put that on you
yeah now he's [__] here you know and
that's even weirder because in school
like I would never get into fights but
you know you would always have like a
weird scuff and then you would c i
remember I remember pushing my classmate
and I started crying cuz it was
traumatic for me I'm a soft kid I I
pushed him he started crying and from
the fact that he cried it's just I
started crying right and then you go
home but that's a weird and that's not a
good experience to have but it's just a
part of the human weird you know yeah
maybe better to have it then and not
[__] kill
somebody start crying yeah that is it's
like what's the how much does it benefit
you to have these terrible things happen
in your life and how much is it just
shitty it just because now I maybe they
have the option to not have those I
don't know what's going on in schools I
don't hang out too much at them but uh I
hope bullying I don't want to say I hope
bullying is still going but I hope they
or are they all just [__] shook well
I think the people now might be more
interesting than people in the past who
didn't know anything and just believed
whatever the government told them now
it's like oh you I might not be able to
talk to but if I can break through you
like have very interesting opinions on
very specific things that are probably
correct oh oh yeah yeah I mean
15-year-olds now what they talk about
it's insane you know high level stuff
all these isms and all that [__] it
seemed like back in the day people would
fight more and these days with
technology you're able to tear someone's
reputation down it's like reputation
destroying sort of things because we can
send videos of them [__] up or you
know screenshots of them [__] up I
feel like that's the new sort of
bullying is more reputation bearing than
two kids getting in the fight the
lockers did you guys have like uh what's
the MSN did you have a MSN we had a
AOL Messer all that stuff yeah I
remember yeah it was the AOL was
Microsoft no aim I was the mic that was
pretty smartphone I remember razor came
out when I was in high school had to
wait all day to get home and tell the
girl you like at 2: a.m. like just what
do you feel and then you go home the
next day or go to school the next day
act like nothing happened that night all
those weird and cuz you were talking
about that bully I remember I was
confessing my love to one of the girls
it wasn't one of the girls it was my
classmate pretending to be the
other oh you couldn't screenshot that
that time but you could print the logs
this guy would print the logs on paper
and God damn God damn but I would
literally say like I want to you know
have kids with you they like you're 13
you don't damn nobody did that were you
guys pretty traumatized people that were
really [__] with each other hard
because of World War II or
something I mean that's like a deep
level to like [__] with someone my
school was so soft I went to a Christian
School no one had sex like two people
smoked weed I from third to sixth grade
I lived in Poland cuz my stepdad had a
job cuz my stepdad had a job of uh
finding old metal and selling it to
ships very Eastern European uh so we had
to go to Poland and I went to I know
what ships just random building ships
cuz old metal from the war cuz if I mean
if the when the Soviet Union collapsed
War just ends like at one point you're a
guy on a tank following orders next
moment no no body's picking up so now
you have a tank so then all these
businessmen would immediately go to
those areas yeah and scrap I mean that's
valuable medals and [__] so this a very
like a Eastern European whatever movie
type of job yeah Poland step that yeah
but I went to an American School third
to sixth grade and uh and I was the only
non-american at the
school it's a big country it's hard to
get here and then I got see I got
bullied of course right but then I don't
know what you guys did when you got
bullied I did was so I was in the sixth
grade I would hang out with the fifth
and fourth graders cuz they're thinking
I'm cool M cuz my own classmates don't
think I'm cool and my English was so I
mean I was on a third level Estonian
English I have carrot you have carrot
that's all I had and we're going
straight into American Education I don't
know he or she they would always bully
me that I don't know the difference we
have no gender in Estonia [__] we're
Advanced I don't know it's your sh
gender neutral pronouns that's awesome
and then I remember I but it was okay I
hung out with the younger ones then my
mom finds out and that's the biggest
thing is like I don't know if your guys
moms my mom didn't give a [__] about my
gr it's all she worried about is am I
cool number one Mary but wor W are you
getting bullied number one are you cool
are you getting [__] are you like a
normal kid or are you going to be some
[__] in inel [__] guy dides that
help you be cool or did that hurt in
that envir focused on it bad I mean it
in the American I mean my own classmates
they would do game and American kids are
mean on a different level like at least
in Estonia I get punched and then I cry
and you cry right yeah and then the we
have to go to the principal we all cry
parents are everybody cries right but I
remember the American kids would do
games like Let's ignore him you know and
I'm the only non American Psychological
[__] that sucks yeah that's mean as [__]
mean as [__] but to be fair I don't know
why a girly way to be mean too I why but
sometimes kids brain they I just started
watching more movies at home I started
making like website doing weird [__] and
actually improve my English that way
it's called Innovation it's in the air
yeah I mean it's just so so like it's
more isolating you're socially more you
know your bubble so then my mom finds
out that I'm not cool right Calls the
School Broken English to she don't speak
she's she nothing she's like you know
like I remember she blew up on a
neighbor that was speeding and she goes
do you know do you know speed how long
that's how she said like on the neighbor
so she calls to school and she yells I
can hear her and yells like why are you
no
friend yeah my boy and [__] and what
she thinks is cool so I come home uh I
go to school the next day and what she
thought is cool that she'll be in the
school step into my class my mom is in
front of the class with the principal
and
Alles my son are lined up I'm going to
beat the [__] out of you are lined up
and my mother is yelling why are you no
friend and all Anthony everybody Rafa
all these dudes they're G I mean damn
and I'm like she just I'm like Mom I'm
like please Mom go you have to please
don't do this please don't she [__] it
up for you even the principal was like
this why why they let her
gay letting her in was
bullying it bullying you more and then
of
course the riffs the next two months the
riffs oh my God you know that probably
taught
you kill my
mom my stupid [__]
mom why are you no when did you start
getting
cool so then I when I came back to
Estonia because of that experience I was
like full metal jacket in you know and I
in Estonia we moved to a really nice
outside the city Community I could hear
the school bell if I was like late for
class my teacher would come to my house
that's how close small cute private
invested school but I come in fully dude
I'm Ready for War and now I'm speaking
my language so I'm like even before I
went to the you came in with the
American attitude I was writing I was
writing at home like how to bully people
finding stuff out about classmates were
they were they like [__] this
guy Soul did they think you were
American no of course not dude you
didn't tell them hey I'm American you
should have done that that would have
been awesome yeah no uh so you you just
bullied people a lot eth and Ninth I
went hard what happened to them what
what did you do like what's an example
of thing you did to one of the way in
some sense this it's just that mental
[__] that you know it's that mental I
mean I went of what did you do why won't
you say what you did is it
embarrassing no okay I'm trying to think
of a specific like tell some [__] up
you did okay okay okay okay okay let me
think I know I've been I've done some
[__] up [__] okay um I did
one I did one where uh uh where it was
like uh a guy [__] he's an [__] he
was an [__] he was a bully himself
and he was way stronger than me so then
you got to take him down differently you
know so of course I steal his glasses
you know from the case right tears who
did it and I'm such a cutie patootie
with the teachers they have no idea I'm
causing this Terror I would see his oh
he Park like a scooter did you guys have
scooters like those 50 cc I know you're
talking yeah like a moped like a moped
yeah yeah moped he had like a shiny one
with a flame you had a moped in high
school no no not even high school this
is like [__] eighth grade or
something
grade moped we had Razor scooters
bu we had like live scooters you guys
are wild you don't human life at all oh
I I had a I mean mop I my first one was
10 and
bikes what his moped no and I got my
first helmet when I was 16 even my
parents were like helmet I mean you're
going to the store who gives a [__] what
did you do to his moped oh I just saw
news glistening in the sun nobody was
around and he was on the
kickstand
K so you were just basically teach
school a little terrorist like this the
whole time like uh Mel Gibson in the
like except to a child oh and then I
wrote this one girl she made a comment
that I'm
smelly I was smelly I was a smelly kid I
just [__] ran around I was
hyperactive you know uh and I was a
smelly but you don't know as a kid it's
to you delicious you know you don't get
it fck yellow um and she made like a
comment you know every and girls are
mean you know girls cuz girls cuz at
that point you already want to [__] them
so it really hurts when they're mean to
you yeah when you're in [__] third
grade in the third grade some girl is
mean to [__] you punch face I have no
feelings right but it's when you start
to have feelings this girl call you
smelly and she pretty pretty [__] as
they said [__]
[__] she was already like sucking
grown men's dick Jesus Christ but she
was hot so she could tell you were
smelly like this is going to be a
problem she alerted you a little angel
girls at that point hated my energy cuz
I was one of the boys super hyperactive
I would do all this [__] I would be this
guy you know like and uh girls always
hated that energy you know I thought
they would like it they didn't like the
[__] that school I don't it's like a
flip of the coin that you either really
love it or you really hate it and
everyone goes at the same time they I
was just this
weird like moving around a lot and not
cool when you're really see when you're
funny like you know that's cool but if
you're doing these bits yeah doing bit
silly silly isn't my
balls like grape you know yeah you
shouldn't do that you know that's not
funny you know but to me a small penis
with big balls is always funny it's just
funny inside sure yeah it just makes me
laugh every time and it's a classic slam
dunk I mean in the eighth grade balls
out from the back from back what is that
I've never liked that when I was in
soccer this guy would do alien balls he
would like put a scrotom out of his
soccer shorts and like look it's an
alien brain it's like this is just a
stupid the stupidest excuse to show your
balls you're just saying it looks like
that's a very funny that's a funny thing
to me if you would do that to me I would
laugh well what's uh what's your
favorite thing about seeing some balls
what does that do for you so then I
wrote and she
after that smelly
comment smelly thing I wrote
[__]
[__] slot wh like pieces of paper
throughout the year just stoping it I'll
kill you
Jes but that's that's kind of fck that's
kind
of you're leaving evidence you could be
like hey look yeah but I like you
[__] that's what I would say I love you
dream of you every day
never you kill you I'll get guys to rape
you listen I love you that's why the
harder I love you the harder I need you
you know sure you were doing that did
she get affected by it was she like was
she like was she like really affected by
it where she's crying and
stuff I don't even that even know
remember did ever end up [__] her or
oh actually became friends later yeah I
mean in high school and later sometimes
with hot people and popular people you
have to approach an antagon like an
antagonist because and then after you
respect like there's nothing more than
like a hot chick disrespecting you like
at especially like in a comedy show and
I say hey you look old you [__] [__]
and they'll be like
okay it's weird weird like if you're too
nice to them it's like everyone
everyone is nice to me so if you're if
if you're nice to them you're just going
to get filtered out with everyone but if
you're mean to them then you're getting
past their normal autopilot responses
yeah going a lot of but you're going to
be cute too and I wasn't and that was
just I already knew it you got to be
cute to you got to be cute when you did
you start working out in high school
yeah then I was he's not like the
buffest guy I just think you have good
bone structure not maybe not now but
also the competi you grew into it I grew
into I would say yeah man are face yeah
you look like a late bloomer you look
like a Perpetual child like haly Joel
osmet or something oh yeah yeah you
think that you have any like Aryan blood
in you what's that like white blood
German no yeah of course something we're
all mixed there in Estonia dominant
features previl what did Estonia go to
Blue
Viking
rape makes sense works out in Estonia
you guys have water there later how do
the Vikings get to the time horrible
experience
later you know so uh what do you think
about the little boy what a room huh
what a room crazy Jesus Christ yeah it's
[__] wild but that all like we've all
performed there but that whole like uh
like it's
definitely like been to the back of the
Celler never on stage there but I've
been hanging out there and [__] and it
feels also very cool like you see from
the movies and all that but there's
nothing more I I I've never had a more
intense like first set at a new club
than mother Mothership just because I
mean everything's going on there and
like I remember this security they give
you water everybody's super nice to you
you know everybody make sure that you
have a it's almost like your you're a
tourist of Comedy mhm you you sometimes
even forget oh I'm the ComEd like I'm
actually supposed to go on stage and
dominate and be the entertainment you
know but there you feel like giggly you
know you're like everybody's so nice to
you and [__] tell people about your path
it's like Disneyland for comedians it's
exciting yeah it's fun yeah yeah
absolutely yeah it's super and then I
mean first I mean first set is go to The
Green Room uh AR shafir Mark Norman Ron
White I mean it's just crazy already
right yeah Hans Kim H Kim oh yeah yeah I
mean I saw you later I saw you when you
went up on kill Tony was that the first
time that was the first day yeah yeah
yeah I to William Sam Talent Sam Talent
got me up there yeah my guy Sam's best
mud great special Sam's awesome you look
like Sam Talent if he lost the we like
he sees a lot of himself in
you I don't see it
who do I look like huh well I know Sam
talent's are very talented guys okay
let's get this Justin Timber
maybe no you know that's uh that Jude
Law kind of oh yeah I can see that Jude
Law you get that one a lot you hate that
you have a deep head why why Jud La is
good your head has has a lot of uh dude
I'm literally
him no man f one of the scars guard
yes I remember somebody said that to me
like 10 years ago and I've been running
with
it I get Mr Bean aot like Indian Mr Bean
I get Rosie old
[Laughter]
donnald I think Harold and Kumar I get
John Candy a lot that makes sense I see
it but you know Dylan used to be
ripped I used to look like Anthony Jess
kind of yeah I used to rap no like a
version yeah I used to I used to be like
pretty into lifting and working out and
got all hot got to see how you guys live
for a bit oh really yeah holy [__] why
are you looking at Anthony and not me no
I was looking
at that was the first time during the
podcast he lived over there so he made
sure not to look
at no I mean Hans you got a great
personality have you ever played in the
bottle yeah remember when you would
really try to rig it so it's not the
ugliest
chicken no I've actually never actually
played so much fun played it but what if
it lands on a dude oh you be K is it
like gender specific uh kiss or no it's
do or Dare Truth or Dare or D sorry yeah
Truth or Dare and we're both good the
truths are just as delicious as they
yeah if you ask the right questions yeah
exactly and you know giggle with like
girls and [__] they would say crazy [__]
yeah they gotta they got to bring that
back into adult
parties spin the bottle you want to have
a comedy show called Truth or Dare but
then again 30-year-old
truth I hit a guy with my I used to
write [__] to a girl's [__] school
bag all year yeah what said that on a
podcast or can't be that
bad I was walking with a friend in New
York and he's like look at this guys and
he takes a mopit handle and just pulls
it down I was like dude that wasn't
funny that's some guys it's not just
like the cities or something he's going
to wake up and if if you tilt those
things over it's not good for the gas
thing it gets all in the wrong places so
he's going to wake up tomorrow it's been
on its side all night and there's a
specific way you have to lift those
motorcycles cuz they're so so
heavy you might not know but yeah mopeds
you shouldn't [__] with mopeds when you
guys like when you guys like the girl
you know how I wanted saying with that
girl writing those notes when you guys
like a girl when you were younger did
you also lose your mind I had so many
girls where I would do it's not that you
actually if you're a kid you're not
doing any it's not the repercussions of
an actual I don't think I was like you
though but I was like just I think
you're more of a doer which I think is a
good thing obessive he passport with her
name as using my surname already married
weird yeah this one oh my God this one
girl I would like I would like every
time I would drink even a little bit you
know just even a little bit with friends
have a cider you know behind the [__]
behind the store get buth grade even
younger like seventh grade you know
trying couple of stps and you [__] up
yeah heart of course yeah oh my God got
estonians oh yeah so backwards and long
drinks which is like sugar with [__]
booze and I would just I would drink
that and then I would go home and just
go outside of this girl's house and just
stand there jesz but just imagine you're
driving drunk on driving drunk on your
moped and then always walk home past her
just imagining things you know what I
did I was like really obsessed with one
girl and I just didn't talk to her at
all yeah and I just had a crush on her
from 8th grade to 12th grade and the
only reason I had a crush on her is cuz
my friend Ryan mckenny had a crush on
her uhhuh so I was like oh yeah and so I
developed a crush on her so that was it
was like so pathetic of me and that's my
relationship with women yeah I just
stare at them from afar I used to just
have a buddy call a girl that I liked
and I would be on the line just
listening wow just to hear if maybe she
said anything accidentally jerk off to
your friend's voice no I
busted hey John did he ever have sex
with her and you were like close that
would suck that be no never happened
this was like when I was like sixth
seventh grade wow I did that in the
ninth grade my cousin he was in the 12th
grade it's already slaming M really I
had a house free and I had like a house
party M house party where I go inviting
lots of friends all I invited was him
and his girlfriend I told oh there's
going to be tons of people
all I did because to hear them [__] you
just cooked
yourself yeah was it like a science
experiment like okay go ahead they were
upstairs I was on that I was on that I
remember they were upstairs and I could
dude heartbeating and I was on the
stairs why would they [__] in the house
when it's just them to and you they both
live with their parents
too you were just like trying to
facilitate a little [__] so you got them
drunk and
then I did all my mother's booze [__]
you're you were a Setter uper you're
like the fluffer and then I was just on
the [__] staircas blood I mean you're
hearing sex this is [__] this is it
this is crazy jerk this is number one
not that by the stairs not that brave
but then go to my room
a next day that's that's better than
watching porn that's healthy how old are
you and you'll never get that back just
when it's the I mean I should have done
that I should have like 14 stepped up my
creepiness it was theep had a glass on
the there yeah it was like 14 15 16 you
know when you're you you you're just
remember cuz you start really wanting
actual P like knowing what you want thir
I mean before that before that I mean
when you're eight you don't want to
[__] [__] your hot ass cousin yeah
you actually do want anime but when she
puts you on you know she takes you on
her lap tells you you're a good boy and
you're close to some tits it just you
get that you know it's just weird when I
was uh doing taond there was this woman
named Heidi she was like 17 and she was
like in the professional and she was
like bigger than us and I would always
dream of like touching her [__] and
stuff and it was like she was bigger
than me but I was still attracted to her
in like a weird sort of way like an
Amazon Warrior
as a [__] I don't know how it would
have worked but yeah I don't know what I
would have done with her if I had oh
yeah that's the best years where you
don't know actual I mean I saw
penetration when I was like 11 or 12
maybe from the internet that's when you
know and that's when it clicks for you
you're like this is this is that that's
my whole life this you live in a country
that my VPN pretends to be you probably
saw the craziest [__] crazy I mean yeah
I mean these days kid I mean I remember
when I was like 12 13 saw the horse
[__] a dude and [__] like that that's
all [__] up you know yeah Mr hands
that's from my neck of the woods claw
yeah they're very embarrassing Mr two
girls one cup yeah all that stuff but
then yeah then you're 13 14 15 17 you're
so and you then you know that you want
[__] and those years are like
Interstellar years you know they take so
long 14 to 15 is literally forever and
the whole time you're thinking how to
get I'll do anything to get closer to
[__] mhm and I remember when you get
laid and my I think I was 16 but I lied
I was 17 and when she found out she put
Papa Roach on you know Papa Roach yeah
you know she would blast it blow your
mind and then we both cried like she's
you know leaning on the door and I'm
leaning on the why are you so
dramatic leaning back to back what is
going
on me that the past is real te my heart
open you know both what and then so are
you dude I was when when I got finally
[__] I would [__] her every [__] day
so and we would cry that's amazing I
never feel like I got laid I got laid
when I was like 21 so I was like already
past all that super new energy so I
wasn't like super excited to [__] but I
lied I was older yeah just because she
was also older you can't there's no way
you're going to get [__] if she's 17
you're 16 that's literally like a I'm
like a child you know is that why you
cried or were you going to cry anyways
at the age have anything to do with I
was about to miss out on [__] CU she
was mad at you this is tragedy this is
suicidal tend I and I remember I we have
multiple fights dude I need [__] so bad
if you get it for the first time I would
tell her like I'm going to kill myself
you every
when we fight I'll kill her kill her cat
I remember I told her no no really I
would I'll kill your
[__] that's normal that's normal in
Estonia
right time I was like she's crying I
like kill your dad like yeah lit like
and her dad was like sick at the time so
it was easy with oh my God if you leave
me I'll kill you a bad person this is
why Ari has no friends why Ari no
friends
yeah he threatens my
family oh yeah then that's okay I guess
have you ever uh been
arrested yes but nothing serious no no
I'm not up what was it for Crime guy a
crime guy I'll [__] kill your dad I'm
not a crime guy no this is love and you
know tell me I'll cut your dick off when
you're sleeping with scissors of course
yeah she was Russian she was insane dude
love language yeah yeah
then you
[__] the best time oh when my cousin
banged that girl you know what I did the
next day go to the bed where they bang
smell the bed
but you know put the what's the sheet
cover cover in it do the pillow with the
smell of the girl it squee it in my face
and all right this is getting really too
personal this is more lighthearted
love this podcast already he's like I
don't want to smoke the unknown product
here I
will I will admit to uh later I found
out from the smell that it was actually
my cousin's colog smell so
strong you at the moment to you
accomplish the goal and that's all that
matters well yeah I mean I think sex is
awesome I'm glad that you had it the
most Estonian way possible are you like
uh every wondering like how much of uh
the history of Estonia affected your
birth cuz you said you were a former
communist are you like did you believe
it or were you just caught up in the
country it's just what's the regime or
wait you have Korean parents right both
yeah yeah yeah but they're close
to say they're close to you're
genetically close to some trauma as well
right yeah a lot of trauma I'm think I'm
very affected by it because uh like the
Bodo League m M the student protests
where they were killing people they were
killing like 200,000 people when was the
Korean
War oh yeah so they're pretty [__]
20% of North Koreans died Jesus really
yeah what the hell they carpet bombed
everything in North Korea wow well not
enough as it
seems it so yeah I mean uh yeah like the
[__] Japanese Occupation my grandma
speaks Japanese oh really she watches
Japanese shows Japanese yeah they had to
walk from one place to the other it's
like New Jersey walking across in
Estonia the Soviet occupation was all
about the the concentration camps but
see people think Nazis just got good PR
but if you look at the numbers you know
Russia way more than Nazis ever like
Googs and stuff exactly my grandmother
literally escaped the gulag when she was
like 14 built a raft ate potato skins on
the raft you know coming down to Estonia
and then the neighbor some [__] you
know saw that she's back reported again
Dam and then she got taken back escaped
again Terminator still alive she's like
91 angrier than ever there's like a
Russian guy living above her and there's
little holes on a roof cuz with a broom
she just [__] and every day just so
angry at this guy W that's a fighter and
when I was like a kid she would always
tell me like crazy stories like my
grandma every time I would have like
friends over we're having like [__]
Kinder Bueno you know like do you have
chocolate Kinder Bueno you know Kinder
Bueno is that chocolate what is that
it's like a it's like a chocolate oh
yeah
Kinder buen bu was in the Coast Guard H
Anthony was in the Coast Guard in the
military yeah oh yeah six
years was that that the Coast Guard yeah
I was just wondering about Anthony's
past cuz we heard so much about you of
course of course of course of course I
didn't
mean I didn't mean guy I was enjoying
the psychoan
story I that you have a lot of stories
too from your you know you're from bang
whatever Bali India yeah nothing crazy
now I just I was very nice to women and
uh yeah for sure I love them good good
man you should model yourself
after got Ked I got kicked out of the
Coast Guard and you shot like guns at
people I just at the water I never shot
a person we just shoot the water do you
miss that you miss the pink Mist that's
what they say right I wish when you
never got to blow someone's head off
blue Miss just shooting water Le just
shoot grenades in the water a little
grenade launcher thing on the
boat did you res anyone uh I didn't
personally my ship did a couple times
it's like just in the bottom eating I'm
just bottom eating snack they're like
people the big thing X Coast Guard do
they do that in the states too that uh
American coard right uh that they you
guys go to Somalia and private
contractor to those boats you know some
guys do I know some people have that's
in Estonia big like all Coast Guard
members they they go to they do that
they do like security paycheck yeah but
shoot pirates there was action there
yeah they shooting Pirates every day
yeah all the time just this little dude
and if have you seen those video looks
kind of fun yeah dude and it looks The
Wire and you the water
jets don't you and they throw blcks at
you they have like slings or
something AK-47 RPG the wrong way I and
they have like a barrel on the stairs to
the whatever Captain's Nest so they can
just release it and then bar
likeon yeah I didn't do anything crazy
though I never was like in a fight or
any crazy resue I smoked I got kicked
out what I got arrested I got arrest I
got arrested for smoking weed MP right
in in New York or in Florida wow damn
yeah I actually I turned myself in you
first you you took the [__] path yeah I
was just paranoid I smoked weed and I
got super paranoid and then I thought
there was going to be a drug test so I
was like you know what I don't want to
go out what failing a drug test you
turned yourself so I came so I came
clean and then they're like all right
and then they they came and they
interviewed me and then they arrested me
it's the bitchest thing did you get you
didn't get any time obviously no I
didn't go to jail or anything are you
dishonorably discharged no I get all my
benefits and everything I served six
years I had a pretty good record dude
you get [__] you are such a good
person man of course yeah to to turn
yourself in for smoking weed that's how
you know he's no Ed Edward Snowden
that's how you should that's the problem
with the military guys like you should
be there but then the [__] murder
rapist that all sober just [__]
waiting to go over there are the guys
those are the guys that need [__] oh
dude I know former military guys I mean
I know a lot of guys that are like we
have compulsory military in Estonia and
for a lot of guys that's a great career
choice and they're literally they're
literally Heroes they're thinking
they're saving the world you know that's
a Louis but that's what they think you
know but still it's V valid and [__] but
I know some dudes who are messed out
ready to go for sure it's it's crazy
they're fun work with yeah they're great
guys to me they're great guys to me you
know that's like a thing that we pass
down through generation every generation
there's Warriors that you need that are
Psychopathic and there's probably been
like a healthy Cadre of them just
passing their jeans on such a [__] if I
would have to shoot somebody Jesus
America's been in war for every year of
his existence except for
17 so we've always had people just
running around killing people just in
our kind of just breeding spreading
their yeah well we got to make
money yeah war is a great Money Maker
you can just take things from people you
don't have to work that hard how okay
I'm not a guy I don't know stuff how
does it I know yeah War makes money I
know I can recite
podcasts but how does it make money
you're taking things from people what do
you mean you're blowing now is mine but
one soldier is like what is it 1.27
million that's a lot of money that's
what I'm saying but that's not blowing
up there's a standing at basis so how
does that work tell me that well you're
spending money on them right that's what
I'm saying so those companies are making
money all those companies that make all
those products for the military okay I
get that the product yeah contracts
contractors oils whatever okay oil what
how you make oil and we got a cut cuz we
invaded you it's like a [__] uh okay
the Land part I yeah that's what they I
think that's what they're that's what
Alex Jones is yelling that in Ukraine
they're like telling them oh yeah we but
you got to give us you want to build
highways guess who's building them Fred
and Bob mhm uh I know that that's
probably right okay I get that but but
that's just like taking from whatever
they were making like if they sell
bananas you're just taking from the
banana fund that they have because if
they're paying taxpayer money to build a
bridge that's $10 million for $100
million you're just extracting from
their uh
banana farming thing so the best place
to live in the world is uh like Estonia
where you don't have [__] to
take America you guys when you got
something you guys are cuz yeah well I
heard this congales guy be like Chinese
are sending their intellectuals they
come with the contract you don't like it
okay we'll make it better Americans send
in their military it's like oh you say
no to us good luck yeah but like the
Chinese are more like you know better I
guess suit case I guess morally better
but less ficient or I mean maybe they're
using soft power remember China is like
building like schools and buildings in
Africa just to build rapport and [__]
did you hear that from
china.com and what are they teaching in
that school let me guess there's a
picture of a guy in every classroom let
me get and it ain't the African one you
know what I'm
saying let me guess Jesus let me guess
black p where are you getting that new
news from we chat you [__] call me
[__] so capitalism is
great I don't know [__] about Capital
all I knows Denny's which is reflex big
part of it I feel you know cam Patterson
knows a lot about snapis because he's
always
snapping so yeah I mean I think uh you
know it's sad that different countries
are struggling
um do you think
uh uh white people have been pretty
destructive you think
overall I gotta head to the show great
to be on here
huh what what shows do you guys have
today I'm doing a bottom of the Barrel
wow I'm GNA go at the world famous
Mothership Jesus at the world famous
mother and you're just rocking up
[__] late you don't give a
[__] thank you Dylan thank you guys yeah
see I'll see you
Dylan you're a
killer later chat
Che I've been bringing you up all the
time one of the funniest one of the
funniest in Austin kills it hard to
follow he's doing The Comedy Store in La
the world famous comedy store January
January
24th holy [__] look at this San Diego
what what
club good bar on the 25th anyone can
hear this and then on the
27th uh a brewery just check out my
Instagram now I B Dylan shiv on
Instagram later guys
see Ro what spots you doing tonight dud
I have nothing literally I got nothing
either I am I'm nothing book I was going
to see if I can Linger on to some shows
did you do the crew show last night yes
I saw you in there I didn't like my set
last night oh I didn't see your set [__]
I went up on the cruise show I didn't
feel great uh yeah I tried some new ah
you know it's [__] did you do five or
three I five yeah I don't [__] five is
so tough
dude it's good for your style to have
five cuz you get that constant reset if
I start bombing it's over if I start
doing badly uh the recovery it ain't
going to be snappy snappy you cuz your
like personality is so important I don't
know dude I'm just [__] oh we cuz
you're an energetic comic and if it goes
good no like yesterday I did uh
sometimes I do when I draw a new bits I
leave it at the stand cuz I'm more
physical okay so I don't get to be that
but then you're physical in another way
you know sure sure I feel like at Sunset
that works well for me if I just do it
from the stand like I don't give a [__]
yeah I think that's awesome cuz then
it's more like an art form then you're
like hey pay attention cuz in the sunset
I feel like it might not always feel
like a room for comedy so people don't
have the same view of it at the
mothership it's like oh yeah this is a
comedy place so you know to respect it
but at the sunset is like this could be
a music venue right so I think people
like see it in a different light so if
you're like narrowing down the variables
and being like hey this is the mic stand
I'm sitting here like a comedian then
it's easier for them to get into that
hypnotic trance of like comedy that they
saw from growing up Jerry Seinfeld yeah
it's because I mean literally little boy
is a small theater because the attention
is purely on you which is a powerful
thing to have and when you're adding
nuances well that's what they say that
uh you it's a classic story guy from
headlining rooms from good rooms goes to
a hell room and just doesn't have it
nothing's Landing why because he's not
fighting for attention during his set
which is all you do coming up I mean
Seattle you know how it is right you're
getting attention yeah which is also
very very it's a great refinement so
you're always compressing like I got you
I I'll give you something boom I got you
like that here's another okay this guy's
passing by is it worth it to engage
physically or just let it go by how are
they feeling constantly you think the
sunset is like that oh uh and that's why
I really like the sunset because those
are exactly the rooms I came up with
where you just have to understand
that that it's it's about that Sunset
it's not it's not even bad you're not
fighting for attention but you just have
to do a different you have to fool them
a bit of a different it's more like bar
it's like you're at a bar like a rough
and tumble and you're trying to prove to
these rough rednecks that you're those
are the best sets I have sometimes are
at those bars where because it's so
animalistic it strikes at the core and
I'm scared I'm [__] terrified it's
not as intellectual and oh ho I said a
smart thing yeah yeah that's another
thing that you know Spectators think
that oh that performing a Mothership
must be scary [__] no dud I'm scar at
the three
people with us with the then you look
like an idiot I don't want to look like
an idiot yeah there you're a comedian
everyone respects you the stage is set
you don't look like an idiot you're like
hey I got up here you can't do
this yeah those are the the intimate
ones are the ones where you really get
scared but if you can not care like
that's why I like black rabbit a lot
right it's a great room low ceiling of
course yeah it's a room it's a great
room as well but even there if there's
two people I don't uh cuz that's exactly
the rooms all I did there was this one
room in Vancouver used to do Suzie used
to run it used to be called [__] bomb
shelter and it was just basement
uncomfortable
hot Spotlight is [__] the mic cuts out
it's like yeah yeah it's not like
[__] premere but it's just that
compact energy and that connection and
the rawness when you're doing your Club
[__] there doesn't think I'll fly cuz
people I'm [__] here this close why
are you going like yeah yeah you know
what's wrong with that that that might
work in a small room cuz they're like
well that's so zany ha cuz they're all
liberals I've done that too at those
rooms yeah absolutely I'm a physical guy
and I of course but then there's some
nights where I remember I did I did a
show I did a show Jo in Vancouver for a
couple on their first date they're
married now they still DM me I had to do
an hour for two people and I would say
there's a 20 minute chunk that I'm still
wrestling with from that set because it
was so beneficial and it was like a
great yeah yeah because the expectation
is fear I'm in the back having a panic
I'm trying to convince please the booker
you know when you're not saying cancel
the show but you're like going like I I
don't care the money the money I don't
care I don't care but actually I'm I'm a
[__] I'm a scared you don't want to
risk
artistically so you're like cancel it oh
this is a good good question it's good
to do it would you rather get slapped
like or would you bomb like Joy Koy
which experience would you rather have
publicly I don't know slapped or Jo Joe
Koy I'd probably go
slapped depends on if it's like one of
those power slap people from the public
humiliation that's bad for your brain
but if it's just like a girl like
slapping me like cuz she's mad no it's
Will Smith that's the scenario Will
Smith famous oh yeah that's not bad no
Will Smith I'd get slapped by Will Smith
yeah that was just more like that was
90% yes that was 90% I'm trying to think
of your level of like Fame that was like
90% just
symbol 10% actual you're at on award
show 5 years from now kilton is one of
the biggest Platforms in the world being
embarrassed by Will Smith you're at the
biggest platform in the world World
Golden Globes Golden Globes has opened a
new live performance K Tony win it up to
accept it embarrassed on stage or would
I rather bomb so you're on stage so this
is a public slap Rick Diaz yeah comes
off slaps you sits down same thing with
Will Smith right yeah or you host for
the
gold I'd rather get slapped me too cuz
the bombing is like I rape be in control
of this and I [__] it up the slap was
like I have no control that guy came up
and slapped
me yeah I mean slap I had a pretty
embarrassing set recently so I kind of
know what that's like oh really yeah
where New Year's Eve what wait which one
I went to the 30th one I went to the one
after that oh wow well use set yeah you
didn't think it was you think it was
embarrassing well a lot of people used
it as a chance to take pot shots at me
you were there right yeah you didn't
think it was that bad no I didn't think
it was bad he didn't have a bad set
people are going to say that because it
was the the EV a minute right for oh
that was New Year's Eve right a minute
bro that's literally impossible but he
also did get it wasn't people are giving
you [__] because they [__] they're
stirring the pot and it's a big deal to
[__] oh that's what happening cuz
it's so fun I'm glad you were there
because it's hard to keep it in
perspective sometimes because it was
like an actual thing that I went through
but it's like hard to like divorce it
from what they're saying about it now I
don't think it was as bad as they're
saying it was I don't think I performed
as well but it's fun to say that you bom
and because you won it's just fun to say
that yeah that's all people are doing
you didn't have a bad set at all people
were laughing you did [__] it's great
yeah and and now you have re people
didn't think I but yeah I mean it's like
people were talking [__] about me and
saying I wasn't good at comedy and I
wasn't funny so it is pretty it's also a
funny thing to do as a hater it's a
funny thing to do right talk yeah
getting slapped that's why you're
[__] there so are you asking would
you rather be Will Smith or Joe Koy yeah
like yeah huh but your level like Rick
Diaz slapping
okay coming up so so you're on stage
you're not doing wellity and then Rick
di slaps you Rick okay okay dude I get
uh I would rather I mean I just went
through it so I feel like it's not that
big a deal right now I guess is my
initial thoughts but I think
uh well the thing with Will Smith was
that that joke wasn't that good either
like he got embarrassed yeah Chris Rock
because he got slapped and that joke
wasn't very good like some of the jokes
that Joe Koy said were like the same
caliber as that one he just gets off
with it cuz he's black and he has a lot
of energy and he delivers it better but
cuz he can make cultural references and
if you're white you're going to be like
ha CU you don't want to act like you
don't know about Black Culture MH about
you know pop culture yeah I didn't get
that joke either just because I I don't
know what G Jane is it's just a movie
about a bald person like you're bald
you're gonna be in the second one Jay is
a actor actress that makes sense it's a
easy connection to make no yeah but she
got mad did she get or was he no Will
Smith was laughing he was like haha we
got mentioned it's okay the camera pans
away and then he the next thing you know
he's walking up so you know they share
the look they probably have that footage
yeah cuz they got it but then there's
also that socio economic of black man
slapping another black man that's
happening there as well you know cuz
it's still a a big platform and all that
you know like I'm built to be slapped
you know like if you slap me it's going
to be slapstick you know that's [__]
Benny Hill
[__] you're so bendy you probably go
with it a little yeah yeah probably like
if you slapped me at a high stake
situation it would just be funny at the
end you know yeah but there's that weird
thing that the that that's what another
black comedian was explaining to me he
was like no you don't get it cuz in my
head I was like so bad but he was like n
you don't get it it's like you know a
top [__] billionaire Entertainer
slapping or a top billionaire in their
Community as well you know so there's
that but I would also get SLA because I
don't cuz yeah when you're bombing
that's your you what you
created yeah you deserve it you deserve
to be physically
harmed I remember when I had a private
gig like a what is it corporate that you
call right it's not corporate but it's
just somebody hired me for a gig and I
remember uh I get to the gig and it's
like you know hotel and I'm like oh it's
in the conference room of the hotel and
the administrator goes oh are you the
comedian I'm like yeah she goes oh yeah
it's room 27 six and I go wait what it's
in the room and as I'm in the elevator I
was like three four years into comedy I
remember literally thinking I hope I get
[__] cuz I don't want to do a set in
the living room and then I had to go not
in the in the bedroom and then I had to
go it was 12 guys and I was in front of
the bed pretending to hold cuz I'm so
[__] new and nervous pretending to
hold whatever OB so it's a literal hotel
room there's a bed it's a little hotel
just 12 dudes just 12 men they can't get
a conference room
reserved they could just go to a comedy
show that many maybe a shitty hotel I
don't remember but there was some reason
why it was there but they had a party
and they were just it was my management
that just booked it and they just s me
there actually to be fair even with the
shell I think it was okay what were you
holding I don't remember but it was
embarrassing it was all full you know
you go full shell shock you [__]
clear your brain that Men In Black
machine yourself look look yeah socially
you're like I have to do this I signed
up for this professionally I'm a
comedian you're operating at odds with
your natural self yeah because of your
dream and your passion and ideas of
professionalism but even then I remember
thinking I just hope these 12 dudes rip
me apart and [__] me up uh like [__] me
and then instead of doing the set never
thought that then I don't have to do the
set that's kind of gay dude You' rather
that and I remember that riff got a
laugh the ACT didn't but yeah I was like
I hope one of you guys just bends me
over and fact cuz the bed was right
behind I was doing like acted outs
that's their fault they [__] up they
spent money on a weird situation oh yeah
I hope you got
paid of course yeah but don't I remember
those
[__] private gigs when I that that
would all be that because but even here
if you do a corporate gig they don't
standup comedy is the easiest art form
to produce but the most
disrespected that's produced because you
know yeah you got like a table and a TV
on and go go like here go they do that
I've had so I I remember I've had yeah
private gigs where it's like dinner this
is the big table and then they they go
they look at your go AR Mi go and you're
like [__]
bananas have you performed on a behind
the bar before where there's this stage
and you're on top of it and then there's
a bar around you and then the audience
no where do they have that set up in San
Francisco where at or uh Chicago for
paper machete huh I'm up in the middle
of the bar and in Seattle some room in
renting or something were just ordering
drinks in front of you the renting one
Amani runs it or yeah probably that was
a I had a great kick there I remember
one time yeah yeah you're really high up
really down at the bar one time after
that kick the dude walks up to me gives
me $100 like just just as a tip you know
that was a great set it feels like
you're a pole dancer or something
because you're so high up so [__]
high and everyone can look at you but
they have to like train their necks oh
yeah so bad it's so respectful it's like
I should be giving you more than this
but uh apparently you did you killed it
at that like oh yeah wheel I had a bit
there where I did a cart
wheel dude I started off literally
mumbling and just doing kicks just very
physical mumbly kicks yeah but when
you're oh but open mics when you're
physical is the worst cuz it's all other
comedians you
you mean actual comedy no nobody in open
mics wants to see actually something
funny they want to see a guy that
doesn't look funny saying clever jokes
but yeah then again you have to write
that's the circuit I came up with just
entertaining my exactly that's perfect
for a guy like you so you can work on
the thing that need you you would
naturally your style would lead to that
being something that is easy to forgo
because you can just paste over so many
bad jokes with energy
but obviously you
didn't cuz you're very very funny guy
but then those but then but then of
course what that creates is those
there's so many I mean I'm sure you guys
both know you have so many comedians in
your head that you know kill every open
when you were coming up they would just
kill always new riff to' be drunk this
guy's drunk he don't even no notebook ra
ra and you think he's literally and you
and you're getting discouraged by seeing
how this hard this guy's killing every
time you see him yeah but then the club
yuck yucks or something does like a
showcase and they tell him okay you have
three minutes you know cuz he's usually
running light at the mic he's friends
with the owner he's doing a beer it's
his Gamble and his turbs but then they
go three minutes and he
goes he doesn't have an act so it's like
and he does okay but you can see it's
not that not and that's when you that's
when you go okay well in that
environment you just have to do jokes
those work the best you know yeah you
can't just rely on your amazing
personality amazing personal and just
it's it's it's that mental whole thing
of like I'm a real comedian yeah cuz in
that bar remember when we were talking
about fighting for attention in that war
and Chaos often wasse and this is as a
guy who struggled with that transition I
was always the underground killer in the
sense that I would make the ComEd no but
the audience would laugh too cuz the
context of my craft is insane I'm at a
gangster bar where there was a shooting
here in Vancouver it's called 12 Kings
this is insane there's a fan going chick
with big tits who's a she's obviously a
hooker with the guy the bartender knows
me you're drinking beers there's
comedians in the back because if you do
a rape joke they lose their mind the CRA
so it all feels ridiculous you know yeah
but then when you go to a club
everybody's sitting every's [__]
sober sitting down happy and they want
to be
happier I'm out with my wife why are you
yelling with one foot on the stool I
think negativity also it's like yeah you
guys hate me well listen to this you
[__] y'all ever
notice how my balls or your faces if you
did that at to Kings standing
go cuz I mean and it is funny I'm not
saying that's not funny yeah but then
the business part of the show business
comes in more into perspective when you
get into showcasing and I remember when
I did the Seattle scene and the comedy
competition that really clicked where I
was like okay you can make [__] you
can kill at the [__] Open Mic but why
aren't you crushing the clubs it's
because these other guys they have a
plan that it's just statistically
foolproof they have a set that they
introduce their Persona within the three
minutes mhm even if they're nervous the
set will follow through the jokes will
land you know yeah cuz you don't have to
meet them like you do at an open mic you
don't have to like be like okay you're
here okay let's go together then you can
just be like hey what's up guys y'all
ever notice Like Tonight Show you can
just go into because it's an equation
it's like hey we paid for this exactly
yeah and that guy who always kills and
fights for the attention he needs the
tug and pull to happen if there's no tug
and pull there's no perspective for me
to explode on or like use as [__] or
use [__] anger or frustration to
contend with exactly people are like
this
okay and where's the [__] you piece of m
m
g oh and every's like why is he Jesus
alcoholic man this is not normal I this
is a
third yeah you think that's what it is
like intensity like you're more intense
no it's not that but the tug and pull no
it doesn't always have to be you could
also be a qu whatever your act is but I
remember I
would I remember that struggle to the
transition of like yeah okay
professional comedian I and and it's
easy to be those Killers you know who
you were always jealous of they would
show up once a month from the shadow
beer full riff about the
day leave and you're like what just
happened yeah but it's what is that
song is that Estonian no it's a victory
song this is the Viking in you coming
out but it's easy to kill I used to say
this a lot that it's easy to kill if you
don't have chips on the table and as
soon as you start being a professional
comedian accepting I'm going to do this
five what do you do you think it's like
you're okay with yourself and you're
like happy or cuz like in an open mind
you can be like I'm Miser able and I'm
[__] but here you go here's some good
and like when you're at a professional
show you want to see someone who's a
little more put together you don't want
to encourage no but poverty with that
guy who kills every time he he comes in
and you know like Batman and disappears
it's he's doing it on his terms he's
already quit he don't give a [__]
there's no Stakes there's no so if it
can be good he can't do good cuz and
that'd be trying and you have nights
like this you have nights like this
where you just know it's going to go
well you just have a thought you're
excited you're sharp and you know but
too bad if you're doing a weekend a
Chuckle Hut too bad that you're you have
to go
up you're off it's
showtime I'm so sad for you that you're
H The Show Must Go On exactly whereas
that guy who yeah he shows up when he
wants when he feels it when he watches
comedian for the 47th time and he's like
I got it that's why I love Dave
Chappelle cuz you hear about him just
like leaving and just being like [__]
this I don't feel it right now he's a
person yeah and he knows that he takes
care of
himself and I think that's we should all
do that as comedians is sort of be like
uh overall we should just fend first but
it's not good to just be like going on
stage like I'm going to protect myself
tonight G absolutely that's the
professional that's why some guys I was
watching some show in Brooklyn and this
woman got on stage and she was talking
about LeBron and it was bombing she's
like you guys have to listen to this
this is
important
um and just doing this spit about LeBron
that is apparently so important and it
was like oh this woman is like out of it
like she she thinks comedy is something
that it's not
nice yeah this was sad I don't know why
I brought that up no it's I get yeah I
get what you're saying no it's totally
that and also when people are giving you
you know their attention to you
especially if it's a show that's a
weekend show a club this is business
they paid to be entertained yeah and I
get it that you feel sad but I don't
think it has to be so businesslike you
can still have fun and do artistic
things no that's what I'm saying like
I'm that's the that's the whole the
business and the fun if you could do it
you know I think that's what Joe Rogan
is really good at like he is so fun and
has so much fun on these shows that pay
really well all these legends that you
me
that's the that's the common denominator
the E the hardest thing to do in comedy
is not to quit because how many times
and this is I speaking from experience
that also goes in my own hair it's like
how many comedians you see who when
there's you know like three four years
in it's starting to get serious now and
before they go on stage they still you
know have a full breakdown and I always
look at that and I'm like do you
understand you're building a hell right
now that's going to bury you and you're
going to quit this with resentment and
bitterness oh my God emotionally they're
not taking care of themselves exactly
and see and that's the craft of also
being like okay I don't feel like it I
don't feel like being this guy today but
can I find something else in this moment
that will deliver the business side as
much as I can
without hating myself like whenever I
feel a lot of pressure before a set I go
I always repeat to myself like I'm I
came here this is I want to be here you
know yeah even though every Instinct in
my body is saying why the [__] are you
doing this panic attack inducing
horeshit you could just be chilling out
with your girl having a normal job why
am I here having a panic attack because
[__] Adam is watching right but then
you go no I want to be here you have
that strength that's what really
differentiates you know the want it's
kind of gay but I have notes on my phone
like these affirmations whenever I don't
ever say that yeah when I feel
nervous that gay
as to your brother's col this me this
me crying but I read these things that
kind of just help reenter me just like
are they your uh shamak catas or kumak
kakas my kamasutras Kamas no it's just
simple [__] that I write before I go on
stage that's like cuz you know have a
big dick I have a big dick um you always
you always want basically what I wrote
is I always wanted this like this
feeling is like it's good doing better
than my childhood bully Ari matd Ari
Maddy Ari Matty pushed my moped over and
his dad sold it for scraps scrap metal
for ships it's a circular it's a
business you guys have
yeah yeah cuz I don't want to be like
what you describe that guy who's just
like [__] backstage before going up
and then I remember yeah when I exactly
and then when I uh at one point I was
like I believed you know like empty
stomach you're sharp fast at State
stretch you're emaciated you're star
don't don't smoke weed during the day
stay sharp stay but then I remember this
was like a three or four years ago I was
like in The Green Room of like yeah in
Canada I was doing like a road Geck
featuring you know just like a great
audience but it's you know there's no
stakes and I remember just thinking like
if this is going to be my life I'm going
to kill myself before 30 if I have to do
you got have waking moment for the
performance now dude I can literally
like I don't want to do this but I'll
have days where I'm eating a burger as
they're calling me up and I'm a little
Burpy so [__] bit I have to I have to
live my [__] life right you [__] I
can't be here every day you know fuing I
have to and that's funny too and your
also establishing power in that moment
you're [__] straight burp into the
mic fart that's what Jamar neighbors did
he brought a Taco on stage and he ate it
oh he does Super alternative I love it
totally on his terms too you know yeah
he's very creative and artistic
yeah um but yeah I think uh it's good to
eat I think it's good to live a good
life and have like be a good comic that
is a happy comic because if you're a
business and you have a star or like the
star of the business and you're just
like treating him like [__] you be like
what are you doing this is horrible for
business like you got to treat yourself
like a prize
lion pampered yeah and try to give the
star the diva yourself what you need cuz
it's all so ridiculous like if you think
about about it I'm in my 30s I'm doing
five at like the famous comedy club with
kill Tony with you there with [__]
Mark Norman there and all this
expectations in your head you know and
but then I always start when I got
really nervous I start to laugh cuz it's
all so stupid yeah this is all so stupid
just people that I it's such a stupid
profession like we don't need to exist
at all and all these people that have no
idea how much [__] this going on right
now there's Joe Rogan walking around he
might pop in Adam is here Hans is there
Tony's next don't forget it there's a
light that's green the bit are
no yeah yeah I mean uh none of it
matters and I love it's a funny art form
because it didn't exist until recently
and it's just a person in a room with
the microphone and we're like oh this is
a normal way to talk we all decided that
this is how it's going to go and it's
like did it have to be this way like
maybe it's like all
arbitrary but yeah I mean obviously it's
working all you need is a microphone and
you can just talk to people and it's
such an anxious thing cuz like music you
could be like and pause before the next
song but comedy you're like hey what's
up and then you got can't stop making
noise you got there's got to be
continuous noise if there's like weird
awkward silence you better be doing an
act out or something
yeah so inherently I feel like it's you
can't conquer it cuz it re Ires like
humility for the audience and it's the
and it's the dumbest magic trick of all
time you know what I'm doing you know
the rabbit's going to come out of the
hat like you know that I'm trying to
make you laugh and I know that you know
that I'm trying to make you it's a weird
stupid magic where it's not magic and
then I whole time have to be like no I
don't give a [__] that's human empathy
you're like I don't give a [__] at all
bam made you laugh but I'm going to try
really hard to deliver this next
all I ever want it but then I got to be
like so
anyway
it's stupid AR you play like it doesn't
matter that's a stupid because every
music Bruce Springstein he knows he's
number one know like that's why you
can't be like you can't go on stage and
be like my dick is big and I [__]
[__] I mean I guess you can very
funny but you have to be humble you
can't be like a rapper yeah cuz you have
to look make eye contact and give up a
like that's why there's so many like
people that are self-deprecating and
[__] cuz I feel like that's more the
vibe and energy of Comedy yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely absolutely yeah
it's more realistic it's like I'm a
ridiculous person and here's why I'm
okay with it yeah cuz in comedy you're
already because yeah when you're doing
jokey jokes there's nothing gayer than
jokey Jokes which we're all doing so
it's already a stupid yeah you have to
be like and whenever guys well that's
the funniest thing of like I remember in
New York
going to an open mic and seeing like
these black dudes with chains on and
[__] and they and because like white gu
like me and you you two we're built to
bomb sure we look funny when we bomb you
know like it's just part of our white
guys especially like maybe especially if
you have like a Jerry Seinfeld shirt and
you're like if you're this
guy then it's then you don't want to
laugh then it's funny then that you're
not doing well cuz it's bu
I'm already a loser but gold chain you
know glasses and then I would see all
these three guys and they love com they
were so nice dude they were like Kevin
Hart is our favorite this our first time
you know you have to pay to get up I
paid as well I mean I'm [__] up and
coming I didn't do any better either but
uh but I remember them going on and
within five minutes and and they all go
on like bam you know
gold was and then you know we're in
three and then the whole Persona and
bombing with a gold chain on is the
funniest
thing so we're all trying to avoid that
by being humble and yeah that makes
sense we're trying to limit our bomb
well I'm a piece of [__] anyway so it's
fine and kin Hart with like gold and
stuff but they're so talented at the
perspective that they're also like Kevin
Hart people love to hate him but if you
see him he's literally winking as he's
saying he's a billionaire it's the bit
as well he know cuz he's from the
underground he's from the mics he knows
exactly how stupid all of this is and
let's just have fun with it I am in a
leather suit explosions in my back yes
sir and that's funny too so there is a
way to do everything but it's just that
weird comedy you going to have to be a
loser about it or yeah I like uh Bo
Burnham he has a lot of money but he
used it well on the little
things um but yeah I feel like there's a
way to do that self-deprecating thing
and have a lot of money I think
like I don't know I don't know if I can
see Kevin Hart pulling it off though I
feel like he it's like it's too when did
you see him live last time I've never
seen him live
see but just like the do you know how
many every ComEd thoughts of him you are
literally the Reddit guy who's [__]
on you right now
that's literally no that's literally
what you're doing never had it same
special so long I just when you think
about it just like you're that guy right
now that's a lot of Comedy they have a
point that's they come to buker like
this this oh hans's next cing him tank
and then they like you at the end cuz
you're funs yes but this that's not all
comedy you can't just be like I'm funny
live I don't have to do well on my
special like just that he's even new
specialist the one with the explosions
in the back I just don't know if it
worked like I I feel like it it didn't
hit me like oh I get what he's going for
maybe cuz I feel like a good look would
be like oh he's looking at the explosion
it's like oh my god well you also like
in that that's that you know he has a
lot of shitty songs in that special but
he has some really good ones that make
it worth it yes but yeah I mean you are
sort of like Bo buram of Estonia up with
an edge oh yeah you're like Soviet BL
but yeah I mean I think comedy's hard
and it's so stupid it's stupid it's
subjective it's everything it's so
self-defeating it's like the more you
think about it the more you're like this
is I and the more ridiculous it becomes
I remember someone like saying that if
they're like the if like an alien race
would land and see a comedy show they
would kill the guy on stage first even
though if they even though they don't
understand culture and laughter they
would just look at that phenomenon and
be like we got to kill this guy first
for sure cuz it's just the weirdest have
you ever like have you ever done
mushrooms at a comedy show it's weird I
remember did mushrooms at a Kevin Hart
show in Toronto in the arena and how I
got into it I did mushrooms went for a
walk walk past scoa Bank Arena Kevin
Hart boom go on seed.com Row three 150
bucks H
straight high as [__] you just bought it
that day moment everything's melting you
should have tried sneaking in
everything's no you can't [__] sneak
everything's melting and I look around
and it looks so crazy that this is the
art that I'm doing yeah is that so
you're thinking like oh this comedian is
producing such a weird response in all
these people that's dangerous and weird
and we must kill it no it's just weird
if you look behind and you see all these
people just yeah yeah like this
it's because you're feeling it in the
arena
yeah everyone around here
like because and and music because there
in music there's so many different
emotion and in comedy as well uh you
don't always have to like laughs per
minute is such a hor [__] I always when
even when I started I hated that term
people talked about that last I ha
everybody talked the first five
Jim new laugh I'm like I hated all that
aspect of it yeah you know like I enjoy
writing I try to think of punch lines I
try to think what's my closer try to
take out everything that doesn't help
yeah word economy word yeah of course I
think about those things but I've always
had that element of like no but what's
the magic part cuz cuz I remember trying
to download Beverly Hill scope on Kaza
did you guys have Kaza of course Imes
Kaza it's like Napster after Napster I
never use Kaza or Li imesh Li wire lime
wire all those peer to peer remember
remember you would download something
you get like Bill Clinton saying I did
not have sex with that one like just a
random MP3 yeah I'm trying to down B
Hill huh Eddie Murphy I see and it's MP3
I don't get it I thought it was just
[__] 17 megabytes I'm like how lucky
am I the whole movie in Eddie Murphy you
didn't even check what it was like one
thing but they're all wrong it's not
like these days with Torrance and
comments Murphy Asen on Beverly Hills
live at the Sunset Strip XXX porn tits
yeah yeah yeah I remember even trying to
download like oh the new uh Triplex
movie straight up hard to
find that's what Universal got right
they're like let's name our movies after
porns so that time I had my mom would
bring me like biscuits or something
every time I had a porn pop up with some
[__] poor little girl getting [__]
[__] in bus always my mom like walking
remember how vicious those pop were you
downloaded the MP3 of Eddie Murphy and
it was that bit of uh gooni goo and the
grandmother falling down the stairs
right and it's about his alcoholic
father and as a kid my English is not
good my English is terrible I don't get
the cultural economics of a blackf
father violent at home uh the
grandmother falling down the stairs I
kind of get that goon goooo ice cream we
didn't have an ice scream truck makes no
sense yeah yeah I'm laughing tears
laughing at this audio and I'm like what
cuz you hear the crowd I'm like is this
a movie that's accidentally in a wrong
it was supposed to be MP4 is this a clip
yeah and you just have no idea and even
Google was rinky dinky back in the day
remember it was rinky dinky it wouldn't
exactly know what you're saying remember
YouTube before the algorithm before even
the sidebar remember YouTube the bar you
have to know EXA
your Evolution of Dance yeah you can't
rely on the recommendeds no so it was
speed thing and then uh Chappelle show
on MTV on satell what the hell and he's
it's like [__] that 8 stuff for what
it's worth comes on remember hey baby
remember crack baby on yeah baby I don't
know what projects means I literally
don't know what selling crack I'm
selling selling weed neighbor
um
I don't remember it word for word but
that was my favorite Chappelle special
that was when I was like oh man I can
see why they say he's the greatest but I
don't know for you but for me I mean
listen I'm an Estonian kid I have no
idea I don't know what the word project
is but the talent of how talented he is
in his in his art form is translating
times centuries [__] I mean it makes
no sense why I'm laughing right but it's
just one of those things you know just a
crazy thing to see yeah just information
transmitted made you cry Jeff dham
[__] with the doll
Amed yeah but dude I'm 15 this is how
this is kicking Fe yeah this is
islamophobia but I don't even know that
the I didn't even get the 911 reference
I didn't I don't get it but I'm laughing
just because it's just one of the cont
watch yeah
well uh you guys want to call it a let's
call it yeah yeah okay thank you guys
thanks and I know I interrupted everyone
no dude you're I know I interrupted
every leave this on is this recording
yeah okay I know I interrupted everyone
this
podcast that when we had you come here
and I'm sorry about that that's what we
paid for and that's what we got and it
broke I broke Ione thank you I broke the
microphone it stops at a weird time so
I'm trying to figure out when it's going
to stop I'll stop it right when you
break the mic next time I should next
time you should just press record